والله أقولها وأنا متأكد، ومسؤول عن هذه الكلمة
الأطباء المتمكنين اللي عليهم الكلام
مخالفات التعقيم جدًّا صارمة عندنا في السعودية
ما تسوى أنك تغامر فيها
ليش؟
بدفعونك أكثر من قيمة الأجهزة اللي عندها قوة تحمل
فأنت تأخذ الغرامة بعد ثلاث خطوات
مو معقولة كلهم، ما شاء الله، ظلموك وأعطوك إياها
إلا أنك مستحق، وعندك نقص خبرة
وهي مثل الرسام، أنت ترسم وفي لوحات تُباع بمئات الملايين
وفي لوحة بخمسة ريال، الرسام يفرق معه، مهارة
ليش، هذا رسام وهذا رسام؟
لا، هذا رسام عليه كلام، وهذا رسام...
فالطبيب لا بد يكون عنده المهارة القوية أنه يقدر ينافس
اللي يعتمد على الإعلام بشكل دائم، هذا عنده مشكلة
يلا حيهم، اليوم نستضيف الدكتور فهد المرزوقي
طبيب أسنان حاصل على درجة الدكتوراة في طب الأسنان
فكرة هذه الحلقة جاءت من مراجعة قبل سنوات عند الدكتور فهد
بعدما انتهى من علاجي
جاءني فضول كبير أعرف
شلون عيادات الأسنان تشتغل كعمل تجاري بشكل عام؟
شلون يؤسسونها، وكم تكلف؟
أيش الاشتراطات الخاصة فيها، والتحديات التشغيلية؟
قلبتها تقريبًا حلقة سوالف أعمال تجارية في العيادة
تفاجأت من الاطلاع الكبير اللي عند الدكتور
في هذا القطاع والتفاصيل اللي فيه
كيف تؤسس العيادات، وكيف تُشغّل وغيره؟
فطلبت أستضيفه وقتها، بس ما كان مناسب التوقيت
بس ما وقّفت هناك، قعدت بعد كل مراجعة عند طبيب أسنان
أتذكر الدكتور فهد، وأرسل له تذكيرة
وأقول له: بشر دكتور عسى الوقت مناسب الآن لاستضافة، ولا لا؟
واستضفناه اليوم
الحلقة هذه أعتقد بتفيد نوعين من المتابعين
إما متابع مثلي عنده فضول كبير يعرف
شلون تؤسس وتدار عيادات الأسنان؟
أو طبيب أسنان سعودي يبي يستفيد من برامج وزارة الصحة
اللي تسهل له أنه يشتغل في القطاع الخاص أو يفتح عيادته الخاصة
حلقة استمتعت فيها بشكل كبير
لأنه أول ضيف أتكلم معه عن هذا النوع من المشاريع
فأتمنى تعجبكم
حياك الله دكتور فهد
الله يحييك ويبقيك، هذه الساعة المباركة مقابلتك أخوي مشهور
الله يبارك فيك، أنا سعيد جدًّا أني استضفت طبيب أسنان
والله السعادة لنا أكثر، أن نضيف لأطباء الأسنان وللقطاع بشكل عام
بس ما قلت لك، ليش؟
أكيد القلب يحتوي على مشاعر كبيرة
مبسوط أني كذا في طبيب أسنان، وأجيبه في موقف أنا مُتحكم فيه
عندك رُهاب أنت بالزمان، أنت عارف
إي، أنا كان عندي رُهاب، مواقف سيئة كثيرة مع أطباء الأسنان كثير
بس عساها حُلّت؟
لا الحمد لله، بس على الأقل أعطيك فرصة تتكلم، مو تنظف
تنظف لي سن، وللا تحشي لي سن
كرسي الاعتراف اسمه
كيف؟
كرسي الاعتراف
إيوة، أيش سالفتها هذه؟
هذا إذا أنت بتنتقم من أحد، تعطيه بنج، وبعدين اسأل أسئلة
تجي كذا تشتغل في فم واحد، بعدين تسأله سؤال، ما أقدر أتكلم معك
أحس أنها عندكم كذا حركة فرض سيطرة
استفزاز
بالضبط
إذا أنت قرأت الواقع، وشفت كثير الرُهاب موجود ومنتشر
يحتاج الواحد يسيطر ما بين احتياج المراجع وخوفه
خاصةً في، دائمًا يقول لك: الانطباع الأولي مرة مهم
الانطباع الأولي
الانطباع الأولي والانسجام والتناغم ما بين الطبيب والمراجع حقه
على أساس أن تكمل الرحلة، فهي رحلة علاجية
كل واحد عنده مثلًا اثنين وثلاثين سن، فأنت لك أن تتخيل
إذا هو أخذ موقف واحد من سن واحد، يبدأ يهمل في نفسه
فهي برضو جزء نفسي، وجزء برضو طبي
ففعلًا الرُهاب، وهذه ممكن إذا صار في ميانة بينك وبين المراجع
لكن في البدايات ما أنصح أي أحد...
المشكلة يجونك المراجعين المقروصين من خمس دكاترة قبلك
وأنت تصير عليك مسؤولية الإصلاح، وإعادة بناء الثقة من جديد
فعلًا، كبيرة هذه وموجودة في أطباء كويسين
وفي أطباء يحتاجوا تدريب وتأهيل أكثر
فهي تختلف من...
والتجارب موجودة كثير، والعيادات أنواع والأطباء مهاراتهم مختلفة
فعبء المسؤولية يقع على أكثر واحد يكون مُحترف
جميل، على طاري العيادات لو نتكلم عن...
تعطيني تصور على وضع السوق بشكل عام
أنواع العيادات، وهل العدد الآن تعتقد أنه يُغطي؟
ممكن بعدها نتكلم عن أنواع الأطباء
فخلنا نتكلم عن، لو تعطينا نظرة على سوق عيادات الأسنان
بشكل عام عيادات الأسنان، هي تنقسم ما بين فئتين
فئة مستحدثة جديدة اللي هي عيادة الشخص الواحد
وهذه تُشكر فيها وزارة الصحة أنها جعلتها مُحتكرة فقط للأطباء السعوديين
وجزء اللي هو المُجمع الطبي المتخصص
يكون متكون من ثلاث عيادات كحد أدنى، ومنها ممكن يزود عيادات أكثر
فالنوع الأول اللي قلته اللي هو مثلًا أستأجر لي مكتب زي أي شركة
صحيح
وأبدأ فيها عيادة
صحيح، راح تأخذ تراخيص
وفي جزئية مهمة أن لا بد تسأل في البداية مثلًا الجهات المسؤولة
من مثلًا البلدية، وأيش وضع اشتراطاتهم؟
لأن كل بلدية لها اشتراطات معينة
على سبيل المثال المُجمع يكون مثلًا كل عيادة لها أربع مواقف لازم
فإذا كان عندك مثلًا ثلاث عيادات، أنت تتكلم عن اثنا عشر موقف
أيش اللي يخليك مجمع، أن يكون عندك ثلاثة عيادات فأكثر؟
إي، لكن لو نرجع برضو للعيادة الوحدة، ممكن تستأجر شيء بسيط مرة
فكرته بسيطة جدًّا
يكون طبيب مثلًا عنده مهارات جدًّا عالية
أو مثلًا متخصص تخصص مُتقدم في طب الأسنان
ممكن يفتح العيادة هذه
ومنها يستعين بخبرات المتخصصين في بعض المجالات النادرة
كأطباء زائرين عنده
هنا ممكن النموذج هذا ينجح وممتاز جدًّا
وصُمم لحديث الخريج أو الناس اللي رأس المال عنده فيه ضعف
للناس خارج القطاع هذا، أنت لما تقول عيادة تقصد غرفة فعليًّا؟
مو غرفة لا بد يكون...
خلنا نقول المكتب
قصدي عشان الناس ما يتخيلون لما تقول: عيادة
فهو شيء كبير
لا، مقاسات العيادات كحد أدنى 3X4
فأنت لما تتكلم عن عيادة، غرفة 3X4 لها تمديداتها الخاصة
ولازم يكون عندك استقبال ومنطقة انتظار
لازم غرفة تعقيم وغرفة نفايات ففي لها اشتراطات
فنقدر نقول: شقة صغيرة
إي نبي نوضحها للناس اللي خارج القطاع هذا، وأنا منهم
لأن لما نسمع عيادة نتصور غير الشيء اللي تتصورونه أنتم
أنتم العيادات تشوفونها، احنا اللي نشوفه غرف، أنتم تشوفون عيادات
السوق الآن، أيش المسيطر فيه؟ المجمعات أتصور أكثر شيء
المجمعات أكثر شيء
العيادة مثل ما قلت لك: هي قليلة جدًّا، وإلى الآن ما فُعّلت
الناس يمكن يجهلونها
هي صُمّمت للسعوديين فقط
على أساس أنهم يدعمونهم، ويدخلون إلى القطاع الخاص
فإلى الآن في ممكن خوف وعدة اعتبارات
أنا أشبّه القطاع الخاص مع الطبيب السعودي
كأنك جايب مُستثمر صيني وطبيب سعودي
تقول: يلا تفاهموا
هذا ما يعرف يتكلم إنقليزي، وهذا ما يعرف يتكلم صيني
ففي حلقة مفقودة في...
هذا هو أحد أسباب تواجدي هنا أن نوصل للحلقة المفقودة ونعبيها
على أساس أن الحلقة تكتمل فيصير في فكر، أيش اللي يصير؟
فيفهم الطبيب أكثر، كيف يشتغل في القطاع الخاص والمستثمر...؟
والفرص الموجودة أيش هي؟ هذه جدًّا مهمة
على أساس أن أنت تعرف، أيش الفرصة الموجودة عندي؟
من هنا تنطلق
حلو
فالمسيطر بشكل عام هو المجمعات الآن
وكلها تشتغل بالتأمين، وللا في مجمعات
تقول لك: أنا بقدم خدمة، ما بقول أفضل
بس خدمة مختلفة، فما أبي أحِد نفسي بالتأمين
التأمين في وقته الراهن حاليًا يغلبه تحديات كثيرة
قبلما ندخل على تحديات التأمين، الأغلب يشتغل بالتأمين وللا؟
أغلب الناس يشتغلون بالتأمين
حلو، وأيش مشاكل التأمين؟
التأمين إلى الآن أشوف أن الشركات الموجودة حاليًا
ينقصها تحدي أو تفاهم مع العيادات بشكل أفضل
منها مثلًا عدم تسديد المستحقات بشكل فوري أو قريب
تمتد إلى ثلاثة شهور
شركة التأمين ما تسدد العيادة بسرعة
إي، فبذلك تأخذ فترات، وأنت عندك تكلفة تشغيلية
فلا بد أنك تغطيها، هذا واحد
اثنين: أن شركة التأمين تعتمد في موافقاتها على أشعة «2 دي»
وعلى طلبات تأمين، فممكن تُرفض
مع أن أحيانًا أدوات التشخيص في العيادة هي شيء إضافي
أيش مشكلة أشعة الـ«2 دي»؟
أعطيك مثال جدًّا بسيط
أشعة «2 دي» هي اللي تحط أسنانك في جهاز، ويصور أسنانك؟
إي، لما نجي لمثال بسيط، مريض أو مراجع تعرض لضربة
العصب مات عنده، تأخذ أشعة، وتلقاه سليم
لكن أنت فحصته في العيادة، اكتشفت أن العصب ميت
فتضطر أنك تسوي علاج عصب
حلو
علاج العصب تجيك شركة التأمين، تقول: أنا ما أشوف داعي للأشعة
لأنه في علاج عصب، فتُرفض المُطالبة أحيانًا، فهذه إشكالية
فالتواصل ما فيه ثقة كبيرة بين التأمين وبين...، هذا شيء
يمكن طبقوا نفس نموذج المستشفيات على أطباء الأسنان
إي، والشيء الثاني، إضافة النقطة الثالثة
اللي هي عملية أن ممكن المراجع هذا، أنا ما عندي التاريخ المرضي حقه
ممكن راح عيادة ثانية، وتعالج على نفس السن هذا
احنا عندنا الأسنان مرقمة، فنعرف كل سن
فعالج السن هذا في عيادة مختلفة، وجاء عندي
علاجه سيء، جاي يبي يعيد علاجه
فالتأمين يقول: مسبقًا أنا دفعت عليه ما راح أدفع لك مرة ثانية
طيب أنا عالجت المريض...، في تحديات كبيرة
إضافةً لذلك التأمين يطلب أن يأخذ تخفيض كبير جدًّا
يصل أحيانًا في التفاوض معهم أنهم يطلبون 70%
فبذلك ما عاد مرّة، أنت عندك تكاليف تشغيلية والتزامات، وما راح تقدر
سعر المواد برضو
ما راح تقدر أحيانًا، فهو يقول: يعتمدون التأمين على العدد
على العدد
إي، ما يعتمد على الجودة والكيف، يعتمد على العدد
فبذلك بعض العيادات اللي لها اسمها الكبير
ممكن تمتص هذا الشيء، لأن عندها سيولة عالية وكوادر كبيرة
فالعدد راح يفيدها
لكن مثلًا العيادات اللي تقول: لا، أنا بركز أعطي المريض وقته
أبغى أنه يأخذ جودة جدًّا، نكون أنا وهو راضيين عنها
وخاصة الآن في 2023 المراجع صار جدًّا مثقف
سواءً عن طريق مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي أو اليوتيوب
جميع الفيديوهات التثقيفية موجودة
فصار المراجع عارف، أيش يصير له؟
فهو يبحث الآن عن التفرد والتميز
صح
فهذا الشيء يجعل العيادات في تحدي كبير في قبول التأمين في وضع الراحة
وهذا يخلي بعض العيادات، تقول: أنا بشتغل بدون التأمين
إي، أنا أبغى أركز على أن أعطي المريض وقت طويل
ويقتنع في علاجه وأموره، وأشوف أيش ملاحظاته
وأوفر له المواد اللي أشوف أنها تعتبر بجودة عالية جدًّا
فهذا شيء يختلف، تفضيلات ما بين عيادة لعيادة
وعلى حسب سياسة العمل عنده
أنا جربت نوعين من العيادات، اللي بتأمين واللي بدون تأمين
تجربتي لا يُعتد بها كمقياس
لكن كانت اللي بدون تأمين أفضل بالنسبة لي
ما أدري ليش بالضبط، قد تكون النقاط اللي ذكرتها
لكن كان إعطاء وقت أكثر، وجودة العلاج أكثر
وحقين التأمين، كنت أضطر أرجع أصحح الأخطاء اللي تصير
فقد تكون مصادفة، أو مرتبطة في التحديات اللي ذكرتها
ممكن، احنا ما ننكر، نقول: أن في عيادات عندها جودة وتقبل التأمين
لأن أنت في الأخير سمعتك في السوق تفرض على التأمين
أن ما أعطيك تخفيض 50% أو 70% بعطيك 20% - 25%
بس هذه العدد محدود جدًّا
فإذا زاد عدد المراجعين تصير قوتك التفاوضية أكبر مع شركات التأمين؟
صحيح
قبلما ندخل في موضوع العيادات والتكاليف، وما إلى ذلك
ودي أتكلم عن الأطباء، الكوادر اللي ذكرتهم قبل شوي
أن الحكومة تحاول أن تشجعهم أنهم يفتحوا عياداتهم الخاصة
وينطلقوا أكثر في السوق
لو بنقسمهم إلى أنواع أو فئات
أنت تذكر قبل فترة، لما تكلمنا عن النقطة هذه أنهم يختلفون عن بعض
فلو راح نصنف الأطباء أو نقسمهم
كيف تشوف أنواع الأطباء الموجودين حاليًا؟
هذه ترجع لتقسيمة شخصية، تحتمل الخطأ والصواب
ولكن من خبرتي الطويلة في طب الأسنان، أقسمهم لك إلى أربعة أقسام
تعتمد على معيارين أساسيين، معيار المهارات الطبية والتواصل
مهارات التواصل، أيش فائدتها؟
مهارات التواصل أنك تعرف تقنع المريض أو المراجع
تعرف تشرح له خطته العلاجية، وتسوي له عرض تقديمي عن وضعه
مثلما تفضلت أنت، أن المراجع ممكن يمر في تجارب جدًّا سيئة
فأنت تكون خامس أو سادس واحد
فبذلك فقدان الثقة حصلت عند المراجع، فأنت كيف تكسب هذا المراجع؟
ودائمًا أفضل وأصدق دعاية أقولها: هو كلمة المراجع لغيره
أنه هذا الطبيب مناسب أو هذا الطبيب...
إذا كان عنده المهارة اللازمة المفروض يقدر يشرح للمراجع حالته بشكل جيد؟
والله هنا ندخل في تحديات كثيرة
الأطباء مثلًا أحيانًا جزء منهم قليل يعاني من الانطوئية
وأحيانًا يعاني ويستحي
بعضهم ما يعرف، وما له خبرة في القطاع الخاص كثير
في عدة أمور ما أقدر أقول لك إياها بشكل كبير
يمكن ما يعرف يتعامل مع الفئات المختلفة مثلًا
ممكن هذه برضو، القدرة هذه
فأقول لك: أنها تعتمد على المعيارين هذه
اللي هم قلنا: التواصل والمهارة
والمهارة الطبية
حلو، هذا بنيت عليه التقسيم
التقسيم
بحسب خبرتك، ما هو بشيء دقيق
ما هو بعلمي
10% يفتقدون لمهارة التواصل والمهارة الطبية اللازمة
ممكن عنده الحد الأدنى بس ما عنده الشيء اللي يقدر يواكب فيه السوق
قصدك زي اللي يأخدون الشهادة، وينسون الدراسة
زي كذا، يدخل القطاع الخاص، ويتفاجئ أنه ما يقدر ينجح
ليش، والدراسة اللي درسها كلها؟
هذه أعطتك الحد الأدنى، دائمًا...
الأساس بس
تروح «دلة» ويعلمك كيف تسوي وقوف للسيارة، وكيف ترجع للخلف
بس ما يعلمك، إذا شطفك واحد في الدائري أيش تسوي؟
نفس الفكرة
أنت تروح «دله» هي الجامعة
تعطيك الشهادة اللي أنت عندك الحد الأدنى
بس لازم تيجي تشتغل على نفسك
فالمريض ما هو بالمريض اللي يجيك مثلًا في الجامعة
المريض في الجامعة يبغى علاج وكذا
لكن في القطاع الخاص يمر بتجارب سيئة جدًّا
فيها فقدان ثقة ورُهاب وخوف، مثلًا ما معه سيولة كافية
كيف تقنعنه أنه هذا الشيء مهم بالنسبة له؟
المراجعين اللي يجونه في الجامعة، مو ناس عاديين عندهم تجارب؟
عنده تجارب بس لما يكون العلاج مجاني، فيختلف
ينزل التوقعات عنده؟
المطالبات
فنقول: 10% يعانون فبذلك يتجه، وقد ينجح في اتجاه آخر مثل الإدارة
لأنه يكون قريب من القطاع
فاهم أيش طب الأسنان، فينجح في الإدارة مثلًا
ينجح في المبيعات أو الشركات
فمو شرط النجاح دائمًا له أشكال وألوان، ما هو مُحتكر على اتجاه معين
وشهادته تفيده في هذا التوجه
هذول الـ10% لأنهم عدد بس أن يطلعون من السوق بشكل قريب
ستة شهور أو سنة، ما يطول
يطلع من سوق عيادات الأسنان قصدك؟
إي، نرجع مثلًا للنسبة والسواد الأعظم هو 50%
50% عنده مهارة التواصل، بس ما عنده القدرة الطبية العالية
عنده اللازمة فقط
عنده اللازمة، فيصير في أخطاء
احنا واحد مليمتر يفرق معنا
في نسبة نجاح أو فشل العلاج في طب الأسنان، 1 مليمتر
فهذه الدقة تحتاج اهتمام كبير
فنسبة كبيرة يقنع المريض ويسوق لنفسه، ويأخذ ثقته
بس ما عنده المهارة الكافية
اللي ممكن تصيب معه في جهة، وتختلف معه في جهة
فهؤلاء السواد الأعظم، بنسبة تقريبًا 50%
هؤلاء اللي كنت أروح لهم أنا قبل
ممكن هم عرفت
30% عنده المهارة الطبية العالية، بس يفتقد مهارة التواصل
ما يعرف يقنع، جزء منهم قد يكون فيه تكبر، في جزء كذا
لأن أنت تقابل شرائح كبيرة، ولازم هنا تحتسب الأجر وتنظر لأنها مهنة طبية
وأنك أنت بالأخير تُعالج نفس بشرية، فلا بد أنك توصل لهذا الاحتساب
يجيك واحد فهمه بسيط، وواحد...
وأحيانًا يكون المريض مُتكبر، نعكس الموضوع
المراجع مُتكبر؟
أحيانًا يكون مثلًا
ليه؟
بس كذا، أنت تقابل أطياف وأشكال من المجتمع
فلا بد أنك تتقبل، وأنك جاي هنا بمهنة إنسانية
فلا بد أنك تشوف، أيش احتياجه ووضعه؟
وهو مجرد أن يقتنع فيك، كل الأشياء هذه تروح
بعضهم التحديات مثل، نقول: الرُهاب والخوف من عيادة الأسنان
ما يعرف يتعامل معها، وما عنده الصبر اللازم
ممكن برضو بعضهم يكون عنده جشع، يعني في اختلافات كبيرة
الرُهاب ما هي بشيء أساسي؟ المفروض أنكم كلكم مُجهزين له
أحس أن كل الناس يخافون من طبيب الأسنان
شوف النسبة والله أشوفها في السعودية ممكن أعلى
مقارنةً بالأجانب، السعوديين أكثر
ممكن تجارب سابقة...
طب الأسنان والتطور الحديث بشكله كبير والجودة العالية
حصلت بداية الألفية، ما حصلت في التسعينيات
والتسعينيات مروا فيها بتجارب كانت أدوات بدائية
أيام الحشوات الفضية هذيك
والله الحشوات تعمّر الفضية، لها عمر افتراضي طويل
بس مثلًا أيام المبارد اليدوية في علاج العصب وكذا
وتأخذ خمس زيارات
خمس زيارات؟
إي، في علاج العصب زمان كانت تؤخذ هذه الفترات الطويلة
خمس زيارات؟ أحسب خمس سيارات، قلت: أيش؟
لا، أعطني سيارة واحدة تكفى
فتقول لي: هذا تقسيمة الأطباء اللي 10%؟
10% يفتقد المهارة والتواصل
50% عنده مهارة التواصل بس ما عنده المهارة الطبية الكافية
يكون عنده الحد الأدنى
30% يكون عنده المهارات العالية، بس يفتقد مهارات التواصل
10% وهذا عدد قليل عنده الاثنتين، أنعم الله عليه، كسب الدنيا والآخرة
فأنا أشوف أن هم 10% نسبة ، هذا يدل أن في شُح
ويحتاج حديثي التخرج يشتغلوا على أنفسهم بشكل كبير بيوصلوا لهذه النسبة
أنت حاط نفسك معهم طبعًا
والله أتمنى، ممكن أكون منهم وممكن لا، على حسب المراجعين
لا، أنا أحطك معهم، ما عندي مشكلة
واسطتي عندهم
كيف يتحركون هؤلاء من الـ10% اللي ما عندهم مهارات؟
بالتطوير، يبدأ يُطوّر من نفسه، التطوير مفتوح
احنا بندخل بعد شوي على موضوع
كيف تؤسس عيادة أسنان كعمل تجاري؟
فغالبًا بتحتاج المهارتين هاتين المهارات الطبية ومهارات التواصل
فشلون تطور نفسك فيها؟
للطبيب الحين اللي يسمعك، يقول: أيش أسوي الحين؟
المهارات الطبية، أنت ممكن تروح تحضر دورات في المؤتمرات العالمية
سواءً في السعودية أو خارجها
في شيء اسمه ورش عمل، وهذه تشترك فيها يعطونك مثلًا
ورش عمل تكون؟
ورش عمل، يعطيك مثلًا مهارة معينة
وتبدأ تجمع تجمع، وراح تصير عندك مهارات كثيرة
هذه معروفة عند الأطباء؟
إي معروفة، وكل المؤتمرات سواءً الداخلية أو الخارجية تعمل عليها
فمن هنا تطور من نفسك في المهارة الطبية
ومهارة التواصل؟
مهارة التواصل ممكن تحضر خطاب
إذا أنت مثلًا تحضر فعاليات اجتماعية
تنطلق في هذا الاتجاه، وتحضر دورات، ما في مانع
أنت لا بد أن تكون مُلم بكل شيء
فممكن تشوف دورات مهارات التواصل، وبالإضافة إلى ذلك
مهارات الإنماء
مع المجتمع
إي، لا بد أنك تصل، وبداياتك في العيادة ما هي بنفس بعد خمس أو سبع سنوات
بداياتك أكيد راح تشوف الأخطاء، وتحللها، وتحاول أن تطور من نفسك
يا أخي ما عرفت تقنع المراجع هذا
الزيارة الثانية أتجنب الخطأ اللي وقعت فيه، أروح أسأل
الإنسان لما يكون هو حريص وعنده الشغف للتطوير راح يوصل
فبذلك هذه الأشياء اللي منها تنطلق
حلو، الآن بنتكلم على موضوع تأسيس عيادة
قبل ما ندخل على الموضوع، ممكن نمر بشكل سريع على برنامج خبير
هذا وزارة الصحة أطلقوه
فلو تعطينا نبذة عن برنامج خبير، وأيش ممكن يضيف للأطباء؟
صحيح
بعدين ندخل على موضوع تأسيس العيادات
في كثير نشاطات وتحركات وخطوات سريعة في القطاع الخاص
لسرعة الوصول فيه لمرحلة التطوير
وجعله منافس، أفضل من القطاعات الثانية
اللي الحكومية وغيرها، أو شبه حكومية
فلو نرجع برضو، ونشوف مثلًا الوزراء أغلبهم من القطاع الخاص
فهم فاهمين الحركة حقت القطاع الخاص
عشان كذا في قرارات تؤخذ جريئة وممتازة، ترفع الجودة
وتفيد الأطباء اللي هم على رأس العمل في الحكومة
فمنها مثلًا برنامج «خبير» و«الامتيازات السريرية»
هذه كلها برامج قرأت الواقع وحللته، واتخذت قرار
برنامج «خبير» أيش يتيح للأطباء من اللي ما كان متاح؟
برنامج «خبير» هو استعانة بالاستشاريين السعوديين
اللي يعملون في القطاعات الحكومية
هو يبدأ مراحل، ويبدأ في المستقبل أنه يغطي شرائح أخرى
بس حاليًا يغطي شريحة الاستشاريين
هنا يفيد حاجتين
يفيد أول شيء الاستشاري السعودي اللي على رأس العمل
أنه أنا ما راح أجلس إلى أن أتقاعد
وبعدين أبحث عن وظيفة في القطاع الخاص
وقتها أنا كبرت والمهارات قلّت عندي
يختلف تمامًا القطاع الخاص يحتاج مهارات خاصة
ما هي موجودة في القطاع الحكومي
الحين أغلب السعوديين في القطاع الحكومي؟
المخزون الاستراتيجي للأطباء الاستشاريين في القطاع الحكومي
لما نرجع مثلًا للابتعاث والإيفاد
الحكومة دفعت مبالغ جدًّا ضخمة في تطوير الطبيب السعودي
اللي تجعله منافس على مستوى العالم، ولا أحد ينكر هذا الشيء
بما فيهم ناس يتعالجون في أمريكا، يجون يتعالجون هنا
يبحثون عن الجودة، عند الاستشاريين السعوديين
فالاستشاري السعودي له جودته
بس أن برضو كلمة نطلقها بشكلها العام، هذا نرجع للتفصيل
فتشوف أكثرهم في الحكومة؟
أكثرهم في الحكومة، بس أن مو كل استشاري برضو متمكن
هذه نقطة لازم نفهمها، بعضهم يقول: استشاري خلاص
لا، بعض الاستشاريين عندهم المهارات القليلة
فأنت لازم، بس السواد الأعظم اللي هم على تدريب عالي
موجودين في القطاع الحكومي
من هنا جاء أن نسمح له أن يشتغل في القطاع الخاص
منها أول شيء يكتسب الجراءة
ويعرف، أيش القطاع الخاص؟
لأن القطاع الخاص بالنسبة للموظف الحكومي صندوق أسود
ما يعرف عنه شيء، ولا...
قصدك أنه يبي يؤسس عيادته مو أنه...
ممكن ينتقل بعدين، هو لا يشتغل
الخبير يشتغل في عيادة من عيادات القطاع الخاص
وكان ممنوع أول؟
إي كان ممنوع، بس لأعضاء هيئة التدريس من جامعات حكومية
كان اللي مسموح لهم
الآن لا، الجميع مسموح له، بس أنه لا بد يكون عنده سنتين خبرة كاستشاري
ويتم موافقة جهة العمل على أنه ما تتعارض أوقات العمل
في القطاع الخاص مع القطاع الحكومي
وتتحدد الأيام اللي بروح يشتغل فيها
فلها ضوابط معينة على أساس أنه ما تقل إنتاجيته في القطاع الحكومي
هو بسوي نفس اللي يسويه في القطاع الحكومي والخاص؟
إي يسوي نفسه
يُعالج أسنان أُناس؟
إي، بس هناك السلم مرة طويل
الحكومي؟
إي، مرة طويل لأن العلاج مجاني، فلك أن تتخيل الانتظار
كل واحد عنده 32 سن، أنت لو تحسبها 10 صار عندها 320
لك أنت تخيل، كم صار لك؟
أيش يفرق فعليًّا؟
كيف؟
هل أنت تشوف مثلًا التكرار على نفس المريض في فترات قصيرة
يطورك بشكل أفضل؟
إي، مثلًا إدارة الوقت في الحكومة تلقاه أحيانًا يطول
يطول؟
يطول مثلًا الطبيب مع المراجع
لكن في القطاع الخاص لا، محسوبة عليه الدقيقة
كل ريال يفرق
الوقت هو المال، فبذلك لا بد أنك تقدم جودة العلاج في أقصر وقت ممكن
بس ما يؤثر الوقت هذا على جودة العلاج، لازم توازنها
بس مو مثلًا مريض تجلس معه المفترض ساعة، تروح تجلس معه ساعتين
مو بساعتين أنك تشرح للمريض، المهارات تطول معك
لأن هذه كعدد وجودة تحس بقيمتها في القطاع الخاص
فالقطاع الخاص يجبرك تدير وقتك بشكل أفضل
يخليك تتمارس أكثر وبذلك تطول
وهذه أكبر التحديات اللي تواجه الاستشاريين السعوديين
بعد التقاعد لما يدخل
لأنه تعود على وقت وإيقاع معين
ما يعرف، مهارة التواصل مع المراجع في إقناعه
غير موجودة بنسبة ما هي قليلة عند الاستشاريين الحكوميين بعد التقاعد
فهذا سهّل أنهم ينخرطون في القطاع الخاص
حسنًا نستفيد منك كمهارات، وبرضو تطّلع على القطاع الخاص
وتعرف، أيش القطاع الخاص وأيش يقدم؟
ممكن أنت تقتنع برضو، وتفيد القطاع الخاص أنك تنتقل له بشكل كامل
أو أنك تبقى على رأس عملك، وتمارس هذا
فهذا الشيء يوفر أول شيء، رفع جودة القطاع الخاص من ناحية الأطباء
اللي عندهم مهارات كبيرة، أنت مُوفّر
لأنه سحب الآن من...
سمح للقطاع الحكومي أن يوفّر هذه الخدمة
فبذلك صار في أطباء برضو مُتمكنين كثير الآن
جزئية أن مسموح له يفتح عمل تجاري، هذه من زمان موجودة وللا؟
يسمح له يفتح عمل تجاري، كيف؟
كعيادة
لا، كموظف حكومي ممنوع أن يؤسس
فـ«خبير» تصير موظف في قطاع خاص، وتفتح عيادة؟
لا، ما تفتح عيادة، أنك تشتغل عند ناس في عيادات
بس مو مسموح لك أنت؟
لا ما تفتح
فلازم تتعامل مع مستثمر يصير هو اللي...
ما هو مستثمر، عيادة بمجمع طبي سواءً كان طبيب أو مُستثمر
أتكلم عن عيادة وحدة، واحد بيأخذ...
مثلًا طبيب حكومي الآن استشاري، يبغى يفتح له عيادة
لا، غير مسموح له
ما يقدر يفتح؟
مسموح له كخبير أنه يشتغل في المجمعات
بس في المجمعات؟
في المجمعات
إذا كانت عيادة واحدة من اللي...؟
هذه الطبيب متفرغ تمامًا، المجال قدامه أنه يأخذ عيادة واحدة
هذه من زمان موجودة؟
لا، هذه مُستحدثة من سنتين خُصصت للأطباء السعوديين فقط
حلو، بس هم اللي إذا كانوا متفرغين؟
المتفرغ...
أو قصدك أنه ما يكون...؟
متفرغ ما هو مسجل في وظيفة حكومية
قصدي إذا كان يشتغل في عيادة بقطاع خاص، يقدر يفتح عيادته؟
يقدر يفتح
فإذا قلت: متفرغ، قصدك متفرغ من عمل حكومي
إي
ليس متفرغ من العمل تمامًا؟
لا، متفرغ من عمل حكومي
إذا كان عنده عيادته يقدر يفتح عيادة؟
صحيح، إذا هو في القطاع الخاص يقدر يفتح أكثر من شيء
ودّي نتكلم بعد شوية عن موضوع الكوادر نفسها
وكيف تستقطبها العيادة وما إلى ذلك، بس خلنا
ممكن نضيف الامتيازات برضو
أيش قدمت مثلًا وزارة الصحة في موضوع الامتيازات؟
امتيازات ايش؟
الامتيازات السريرية، هذه نقلت...
الامتيازات السعرية؟
السريرية
السريرية؟
إي، الامتيازات السريرية فكرتها أن أول كان مثلًا علاج العصب والخلع
في تخصيصات معينة كانت ممنوع الطبيب العام أن يمارسها
إلا في حدود معينة، مثلًا: علاج العصب قناة واحدة أو قناتين كحد أقصى
تلبيسة، مثلًا في التركيبات يسوي تركيبة أو تلبيسة واحدة
مثلًا في الخلع مسموح له عدد ما يكون جراحي أو كذا
ليش؟
لأنه مهاراته، تعطيك الجامعة الحد الأدنى
فبذلك كان اللي يطور من نفسه، نظامًا قد يُحاسب
لو تجرأ وحاول
لو تجرأ
يسوي أكثر من اللي...
إي، ولو حضر دورات تدريبية ومعتمدة وكذا يبلش، ما يقدر نظامًا
فالآن جاءت الامتيازات السريرية من قراءة السوق والقطاع الطبي
فسمح للأطباء بشكل عام أنه خُذ دورات معتمدة
وتعال تحت إشراف استشاري سعودي في المجمع
وهذا برضو في المجمع، خاصة فيه، ما هي في العيادة
أو في العيادة ويكون معك استشاري زائر مثلًا
ويكون تحت إشرافه فيسمح لك أنك تمارس، مثلًا تسوي أكثر من تلبيسة
مسموح لك تسوي أكثر من علاج عصب، ومسموح لك...
بس اللهم يكون معك شهادات لدورات معتمدة
فلازم يكون معك شهادات والاستشاري، وللا بس؟
إي، والاستشاري يشرف عليك
وما في مرحلة ما تحتاج إلى استشاري؟
لا، إلا أن يكون معك شهادات دراسات عليا
حسنًا، فيا أنك أنت تصير...
الدورات يكون تحت إشراف استشاري
حلو، بس وين الامتيازات؟
أنه سمح له يشتغل
أول كان أنت محدود أنك ما تتعدى الحد هذا، مبتدئ مثلًا
متوسط لا، ما توصل مهاراته
سابقًا كان لازم تتعامل مع أطباء آخرين يغطونك
لكن الآن لا، تحت إشراف اسشاري ممكن أنت تنطلق
فصار للطبيب العام حرية أكبر في القطاع الخاص
أنه أحضر دورات وأطور من نفسي، فبذلك أنتج فيزيد دخلي
فيصير عندي حياة وفرصة أفضل، فهذه هي الفكرة
أنا قد مريت بموقف زي كذا مع طبيب، راجعت معه كثير على فكرة
تعرف من القهر أطلع السوالف هذه
الطبيب كان يحاول يعالج أسناني
وبعدين ما أدري أيش كان، مر على شيء في الأسنان
قال لي: ما أقدر أشتغل عليه، لازم نجيب لك أحد ثاني
تخصصه هو اللي يشتغل على الشغلة هذه
صحيح
من وجهة نظري كانت سهلة، أنا كمراجع، يا أخي ليش؟
عندك الأدوات اشتغل
خلص الموضوع
أنت تستطيع
أنت تقدر «رحم الله امرئ عرف قدر نفسه»
هذا مرة إيجابي عند الطبيب هذا، وأهنئه
أن فعلًا أنت ممكن تصل للحالات المتقدمة، وما تقدر
خلاص لا دوراتك تفيدك ولا...
خلاص تشوف الناس المتخصصة في التخصص الدقيق هذا تساعدك
حلو
لأن أهم شيء، مثلما قلت لك: مفتاح نجاحك في القطاع الخاص
هو حاجتين
المفتاح الأول: الأمانة، والثاني: هو الصدق
فلا بد أنك تكون أمين وصادق
هذا الشيء اللي راح يجيب لك النجاح بدون ما تتعب فيه
فلا بد أنك تعرف مثلًا الحدود أو القصور عندك
وتدور مَن يساعدك فيه
صادق، إذا الشيء فيه ألم، تقول: فيه ألم؟
إذا في ألم؟ في ألم، أكيد
رسالة لكل الأطباء لو سمحتوا، في ألم؟ تقول: في ألم
خلّك صادق
خلّك صادق، لو سمحت
بنرجع لموضوع العيادة الحين أنا طبيب راح أسس عيادة
كم ممكن تكلّفني بشكل عام؟
في التكاليف الأولية اللي هي تكاليف تأسيسية
وبعدين تنطلق إلى تكاليف تشغيلية
التحديات كبيرة، كأنك تقول: تعال أنت موظف أبغاك تبني بيت
تعرف تبني بيت وتسوي بلاط، وتشرف على جبس؟
المهم طلعت تحديات كبيرة
فما كلنا...
وخاصةً الأطباء اللي مثلًا انغمسوا في الدراسة لسنوات طويلة، وراحوا
قد لا يتقنون هذه المهارات
فأنت تبي تؤسس عيادة، أول شيء حدد، أيش وجهتك؟
لازم تعرف، أيش تبي، وقديش خبرتك؟
قبلما تفكر في العيادة
هل خبرتك خمس إلى سبع سنوات في القطاع الخاص، أو لا؟
إذا عندك الإجابة نعم، ممكن تفكر أنك تفتح
لا، وقف وروح ُخذ خبرة واعرف، أيش الوضع، وأيش السوق يتطلب؟
أيش المهارات اللي تحتاجها؟
لأنك أنت بالأخير راح تصير الكل في الكل في البداية
لا تجي على طول تطلع من الحكومة، وتحاول تبني
وهذا فكرة «خبير» أنها تساعدك
وحتى الأطباء اللي توهم متخرجين، الدعوة ما هي بافتح على طول
تراها تحديات كبيرة، ودهاليز أنت ما تعرفها
فلا بد أنك في البداية تأخذ خبرة من 5 إلى 7 سنوات
بعد هذه الخبرة، حسنًا عندك هذه الخبرة؟
ممكن تفكر، هل قدرتي المادية كبيرة، وللا على قدّي؟
لما نتكلم على قدّي، احنا نتكلم من 700 ألف إلى مليون
أو تقدر أكثر 3 إلى 4 مليون
هذا من اطلّاعك هذا أقل شيء عشان تبدأ عيادة؟
إي، مثلًا كعيادة من 700 ألف إلى مليون يعتمد على التشطيب
إذا بختار، لو بنأخدها من أول خطوة
أنا بختار مكتب أسوي فيه عيادة
أي مكتب عادي وللا في اشتراطات معينة؟
مثلما قلت لك: أول شيء لازم تتأكد من البلدية، لا تروح على طول توقع
لا اصبر، لقينا لقطة، ما هي بلقطة أحيانًا
أنت روح شوف البلدية واشتراطات وزارة الصحة كمساحة
مثلًا عندك غرفة التعقيم، وغرفة النفايات الطبية، وغرفة انتظار
وعندك العيادة لها مساحة معينة، ممكن المساحة ما تكفيك
ففي اشتراطات من وزارة الصحة على مساحات العيادة؟
لها مساحات معينة
لازم تتأكد المكتب اللي بتستأجره
إي لازم، يكفي وللا لا؟ ما هو على طول توقع
أو مثلًا تجيك البلدية، تقول: يا أخي ما عندك مواقف
ابلش بعد، فبذلك لا بد
فكرة العيادة فيها أمور سهلة أكثر من المجمّع، مرّة سهلة
عشان كذا أنا أشجع هذه الفكرة
وأهنئ وزارة الصحة أنها خصصت الأطباء السعوديين
أنها أتيحت المجال بشكل مرّة كبير
أول حاجة لما نتكلم مثلًا عن التكلفة التأسيسية
نتكلم أنها أقل، مثلًا من 700 إلى مليون
المكاتب بسهولة تحصّل مثلًا عقد طويل الأمد
عشر أو خمسة عشر سنة
لكن في المجمع أنت تنافس أنشطة تجارية كثير
خمس سنوات يالله تحصلها إلى سبع سنوات
ما تحصّل عقود طويلة الأمد، وهذه مهمة بالنسبة لك
لأنها تفرق معك بعدين في التجهيز
أنت قصدك مجمع العيادات؟
إي، العيادة أو المكتب ممكن تحصل عقد طويل الأمد
عشر أو خمس عشر سنة ممكن، المكاتب كثيرة
بس عشان أوضح النقطة هذه
هل قصدك أن عندك خيارين أنك تروح لمجمع عيادات
تقول: بفتح عيادة عندكم، أو أنك تسوي عيادتك الخاصة؟
لا
أجل؟
هذا النموذج أنا ما أشجع ولا أنصح فيه
لأن لها قصور مرة كبير
أنك تروح للعيادة، وتقول: أجروني؟
لا، هذا الشيء...
أيش مشكلته؟
أول شيء لك وللمجمع، ممكن المجمع غير ناجح في إدارته وغير كذا
فأنت ملتزم أنك تأخذ عندهم بعقد إيجار
الإدارة أحيانًا قد تكون غير جيدة، فما أنصح بهذا التوجه
لكن مثلًا أنت كعيادة تروح تفتح عيادة في مكتب
في عمارة مكتبية أو تجارية، ممكن تفتح فيها عيادة
العيادة هذه إذا فتحتها التكلفة عليك أقل
وعقودك تقدر تحصّل سنوات أطول
إي، بس أيش الخيار الثاني؟
الخيار الثاني مجمع طبي متخصص
حسنًا
مجمع طبي متخصص لازم عيادات ومساحات كبيرة
فبذلك أنك تحصل عقود طويلة الأمد هذه...
ليش تحتاج عقود طويلة، ليش ما تستأجر زي المكاتب سنتين أو ثلاثة؟
ممتاز، هذا يقودنا إلى أنك أنت بالأخير سمعتك ما راح تطلع على طول
ممكن تجلس سنة أو ثلاثة، يالله تغطي تكاليفك التشغيلية
وبعدين تبدأ تطلع تحقق الأرباح وسمعتك صارت معروفة
ومشهور صار طبيب ناجح، وعنده مراجعين كثير
فبذلك التنقل هذا راح يتعبك، وراح يقلل عليك
وبعدين العيادة أنت لما تدخل أي عيادة أسنان
لا تتوقع أنها سهلة الإنشاء، تحت الأرض في شبكات مرة كثيرة
التكاليف هذه، أنت تقول: 700 ألف إلى مليون، وين تصرفها؟
كثير، أول شيء عندك جزء منها إيجار
وجزء منها مثلًا تمديدات تحت الأرض
عند كل عيادة تحتاج مثلًا تمديدات مياه، وصرف وهواء وكهرباء
يمكن كل عيادة أسنان تحتاج لخمسة أو ستة مواسير تحت الأرض
الهواء هذا حق اللي تشفط؟
إي، فبذلك هذه لها أمكان خارجية
فبذلك لا تشوف العيادة تحسبها الكرسي يشتغل لوحده
لا، في أجهزة برة تساعد
أحس الشفاط هذا مشبوك بالكرسي وخلاص
لا، في أجهزة خارجية، فبذلك مكلفة هذه
عمليات التمديدات في الأرض، فما هي سهلة أنك تنشف
عشان كذا أقول لك: هل تسوى عليك أو لا
سنتين أو ثلاث حسنًا، ونقطة ثانية راح تفرق معنا
أنك تكسر وتسوي وتشتغل
نقطة ثانية: الأرضية لازم تمد عليها، وبعدين تروح تبلط
وبعدين تروح تسوي الديكورات، وبعدين توفر أجهزتك
الأجهزة، هل بروح أختار أفضل الأجهزة
وللا أجهزة جودتها مقبولة، وأشتغل فيها؟
لأن هنا النقطة مهمة
اللي هي أن لو تأخذ أفضل الأجهزة، ويفشل المشروع، لا قدر الله
ما تبيعها برخص الفلوس
ليش؟
ما لها زبون
ما في أحد بعيادة ثانية يحتاجه؟
قليل، الزبون صعب أنك تحصله
كأنك تقول: بتبيع نورس، من يشتريه؟
نورس بنفسجي
مَن يربيه هذا؟ نفس الفكرة
أنت لا تحط نفسك في هذا الموقف
إذا عندك عقد طويل الأمد، إي ما عندي مانع استثمر، هذا يُعتبر استثمار
أختار أجهزة طبية، ما أبغى صيانة
أنا بيعطوني ضمان مثلًا في الأجهزة الكورية أو غيرها
مثلًا سنتين، فبالتالي تمشي معك
لكن بعد سنتين، الصيانة مكلفة راح تكون علي
إذا عقدي طويل الأمد أنا راح أبحث عن الأجهزة مثلًا الأوربية الأمريكية
لأنها تعيش معي بدون صيانة أو صيانتها قليلة
ما تجي معها عقود صيانة أصلًا؟
عقود الصيانة هذه فيها ضمانات
الضمانات راح تأخذ عليها كلها مثلًا سنتين
وبعد السنتين، إذا أنت مثلًا الأجهزة تحمّلها ما هو عالي
كل شوي راح تحتاج صيانات متكررة، وتطلع عليك مُكلفة جدًّا، في تكلفة التشغيل
فأيش الأجهزة الأفضل المتعارف أنها أفضل؟
هي كلها مصرحة من هيئة الغذاء والدواء، هذا لازم احنا نؤمن فيها
فإذا هي مصرّحة هي مسموحة أنك تعمل فيها
وأنها تؤدي في العمل حقه
بس احنا نتكلم عن سيارة كل شوي مثلًا تروح تصينها
وللا سيارة، ما شاء الله تبارك الله، تمشي بك وتوديك، بنزين وزيت
فهذه اللي تعطيك كيلوات
إي فنفس الفكرة هي
إي، أيش هي، ومن وين؟
الأجهزة هذه اللي تعطيك كيلوات مثلًا أوربية أو أمريكية
معروف تاريخها وأن صيانتها سهلة، وقطاع غيارها متوفر بكثرة
الأجهزة المستحدثة أنك تلقى الكورية أو الصينية
تمشّي معك وممتازة في البداية
لكن تكلفة الصيانة بعدين راح تطلع عليك، لو تشتري جهاز ثاني أفضل
والأجهزة بتأكل من هذه الـ 700 ألف أتوقع؟
أكيد، فأنت لازم تحدد أهدافك، هل عندك مثلًا عقد طويل الأمد؟
حسنًا راح أخذ أجهزة قوة تحملها عالي
عشان أوفر في الصيانة في المستقبل، أنا أستثمر
عندك أجهزة العيادة
أتصور التمديدات هذه كلها بتروح بمكان ثاني في العيادة
مثلًا التمديدات هذه بتروح خارج المبنى على أساس أن عندك مكائن خارجية
مكائن هواء وشفط، فهذه أجهزة خارجية
هذه برضو لها تكلفتها
لها تكلفتها، وعندك أجهزة التعقيم والأشعة
وعندك الأجهزة الصغيرة مثل جهاز علاج العصب، وجهاز تصلب الحشوات
في أجهزة كثير
أنت لو بتدخل عيادة الأسنان أشبهها كأنها غرفة عمليات
مواد كثير
بس كلها نقدر نمشي فيها في الأجهزة الثانية
بنفس القاعدة، الأمريكي والأوربي هو الأفضل؟
لا
أو يتحمل، خلنا نقول
لا، أنت عندك أشياء أساسية وركن، هذه لازم تضبطها صح
مثلًا نقول: التعقيم لا تلعب فيه
التعقيم خُذ أفضل شيء، دائمًا حتى لو أن عقدك قصير الأمد
أول حاجة لأن مخالفات التعقيم جدًّا صارمة عندنا في السعودية
ما تسوى أنك تغامر فيها
ليش؟
بدفعونك أكثر من قيمة الأجهزة اللي عندها قوة تحمل
ليش في تركيز على التعقيم تحديدًا؟
لأن هذه مثل أي عيادات فيها انتقال العدوى
فبذلك لا بد أن تحرص على الموضوع هذا
ووزارة الصحة في الجولات الرقابية والتفتيشية صارمة في هذا الموضوع
كل شيء ممكن يتهاونوا معك، ويعطوك فيه إنذارات
إلا التعقيم على الطول 10-20 ألف
لا تحاول توفر في التعقيم
ولا تحاول أنك مرة
الأشعة، ممكن أنت تأخذ كوري أو ألماني أو أمريكي أو أي شركة ثانية
بس أن حاول أنك تعرف، مثلًا أيش قطع الغيار المتوفرة دائمًا
هي الألماني أكثر شيء، لأنه من زمان موجود
عندك مثلًا كراسي يعتمد برضو على عقدك
إذا عقدك طويل الأمد ممكن تتجه للألماني أو الأمريكي
لكن مثلًا عقدك قصير الأمد، تتجه للكوري أو الصيني
لأنك أنت برضو ما عندك...
هي تحديات مُقبلة، هل أنت بتقدر؟
أنت طبيب ناجح، وراح تفتح، وعندك خبرة مثلًا 5-7 سنوات
بس هل أنت راح تكون قد التحدي في إدارة البشر، والمراجعين ومشاكلهم؟
راح تعرفها وتحلها، ومحاسبين ومشتريات ومبيعات؟
تحديات كبيرة، فبذلك أنت لازم في البداية بحذر
هذه كلها الأجهزة، والمواد أيش وضعها؟
المواد دائمًا أشبه، عشان أبسّط الصورة أكثر
أشبّهها كأن عندك مطعم
المطعم، الزبون جاءك يبحث عن مثلًا غداء أو عشاء معين
فأنت راح تطبخ له، عندك مطبخ رئيسي، راح تطبخ له هذه الوجبة
عندك أدوات الطبخ، القدر والملاعق...
سواءً كانت أمريكية أو أوربية أو كورية أو صينية
أنت طباخ ماهر راح تطبخ طبختك صح، والزبون راح يأخذ الأكلة
أنت احرص على الأكل مثلًا المقادير أو المكونات تكون فعلًا من أفضل شيء
الخضار والأشياء هذه، لأن هذا الزبون راح يأخذها ويأكلها
لكن مثلًا أدوات الطبخ سواءً كانت أمريكية أو أوربية
هذه ما راح تفرق مع الزبون
هي بالأخير أن ممكن القدر ما تحمل وكُسر، أو ملعقة ما...
ما يفرق معه
هو ما يفرق، أنت احرص على المواد اللي راح يأخذها المراجع
أنها أفضل شيء، لا تغامر باسمك
ودائمًا احنا نقول...
أنت قصدك المواد اللي تصير معه، ويأخذها برة العيادة
إي، خلاص راح يطلع ويروح بها البيت
بعيش معها
إي، يعيش معها
احرص أنك دائمًا حط نفسك مكان هذا المراجع
أنك راح تأخذ هذه الخدمة
واحنا بالأخير مثلما قلت لك: لازم أنت تحسب أجر الدنيا والآخرة
فبذلك أتمنى هذه الخدمة أني آخذها لنفسي أو لقريب لي
أجل وين المناطق اللي توفر فيها؟
اللي هي الأجهزة، ومربوطة مثلما قلت لك
الأجهزة والأدوات هي اللي تقدر توفر فيها؟
إي، أنت تختار شركات
والشركات كثيرة، وكلها مصرحة من هيئة الغذاء والدواء
ومسموح أنها تتواجد، وتوافقت معايير هيئة الغذاء والدواء
فبذلك تقدر أنت تأخذ منها
وهنا تعتمد على عقدك وخبرتك
مثلًا أنت فاتح لك مركز أول وعندك خبرة كاملة
المركز الثاني يسهل معك، فأنت عارف ممكن تأخذ أفضل شيء
لكن إذا هي مثلًا أول مركز لك، خُذ الموضوع بحذر أكثر
حلو، فأي شيء يأخذه معه العميل، هذا ما توفر فيه؟
لا توفر فيه
والتعقيم ما توفر فيه؟
وما في ذاك التوفير، المواد الاستهلاكية، ما هي ذاك التوفير
كلها متقاربة وكلها...
فاحرص، صح أن بعض المواد تفرق كثير بس أن، مثلما قلت لك
حاول أنك تحرص على أنه يأخذ أفضل حاجة
والتعامل مع الموردين، هل في شيء المفروض الواحد يكون عارفه؟
لما تبدأ تؤسس مرحلة عيادتك
بعضهم يجي الجيبة مليانة شوي معه 900 ألف أو مليون
يبي يفتح عيادة، قال: الأجهزة مثلًا 200-300 ألف
راح يكيشها على طول، الدعوة ما هي بكذا
خذها أقساط، هم يوفرون لك إياها، ويعطونك فترة سماح
وأنت إذا خلصت مثلًا موضوع المقاول أو بعد استئجارك للمبنى
وتجهيزك المخطط، واتفاقك مع المقاول
لازم توقع برضو عقد إشراف مع مهندس أجهزة طبية
عشان يشرف على التمديدات هذه لا يصير فيها تسريب وللا شيء
فأنت تجيب أي مقاول مع المهندس هذا؟
مقاول إذا هو عنده خبرة طبية بكون أسهل
إذا ما عنده مو مشكلة أي مقاول
بس أهم شيء المهندس؟
المهندس هذا لازم يكون موجود معك، مهندس أجهزة طبية
لأن يطلع لك مشكلة بعدين بالمواسير
إي، ما عاد خلاص يكسر كل هذه الدنيا هذه صعبة
فلا بد أنك تحرص في هذه النقطة
بعدما تخلص موضوع التمديدات، وركبت الآن الإنارة
بس أنت خلال الفترة هذه أخذت جولات
وعرفت، أيش هي الأجهزة اللي أنت ناوي تأخذها؟
في هذه المرحلة وقت تركيب الإضاءة ابدأ تعاقد
بيرسلون لك إذا أنت مثلًا مجمع ممكن الأجهزة كبيرة
فلا بد أن تتعاقد من بدري
لكن عيادة تلقاها في أي مستودع
عندهم وراح يوفرون لك إياها على طول، تبدأ تتعاقد في هذا الوقت
قصدك إذا خلصت تشطيب وكذا؟
إذا خلصت، وبعضهم مستعجل، ويتأخر عليه المقاول
هذا يورد الأجهزة، ما يعرف، وين يحطها؟
فلازم تخلص بعدين تبدأ تتعاقد
بس تكون أنت عارف، أيش تبي تأخذ؟
تعاقدت في الأجهزة، وأوردوا لك إياها، تطلب فترة سماح
السماح، يسمحوا لك دائمًا الموردين من ثلاثة إلى ستة شهور
تبدأ تسدد بعد الفترة هذه
إي، وبعدين يقسطون لك إياها بسعر النقد، ما يأخذون عليك فائدة
حسنًا
فدائمًا حاول توفر السيولة في بداياتك ما تدري أيش الصدمات اللي تجيك
على أساس أنك تقدر تتغلب عليها
منها الغرامات أتصور تجي؟
والله للأمانة، المجمعات الطبية غراماتها قليلة جدًّا
إذا أنت حريص عليها، وفاهم، وعندك خبرتك
حتى لو تأخذ تسلسل الغرامات مثلًا
وأقيس لك إياها على الشؤون الصحية في منطقة الرياض
وإن شاء الله، الشؤون الصحية في كل المناطق أخذوا هذا الفكر
لأنه نظام
القطاع الخاص هنا يعطيك أول شيء المفتش يأخذ عليك مثلًا المخالفة
لقى في مخالفة، وسجلها
المخالفة تعرض على لجنة هناك، وياخذون أقوالك في اللجنة
واللجنة إذا شافت أن عندك حق سمحوا لك
ما عندك حق، أعطوك الغرامة
بعد كذا تروح للاستئناف، في محكمة خاصة وقاضي
في لك حق؟ أعطوك إياه
فأنت تأخذ الغرامة بعد ثلاث خطوات
مو معقولة كلهم، ما شاء الله، ظلموك
إلا أنك مستحق، وعندك نقص خبرة، هذه الإشكالية
فاحنا نجي نقول: فائدة الـ5-7 سنوات هو استثمار في نفسك
وراح توفر كثير
حلو، فاحنا تكلمنا عن تكاليف الأجهزة والمواد، وما إلى ذلك
في الكوادر الطبية الآن
راح تدخل الكوادر الطبية، والغير طبية
بالضبط، بسأل الكوادر بشكل عام
الكوادر الطبية عندك ثلاثة أنواع من التعاقد، إذا أنت عيادتك...
أنت ليش تجيب أحد؟
أنا واحد من برة القطاع أسألك أو أتساءل
أنا طبيب ممكن طبيب عام، وأقدر أستلم الحالات هذه كلها
اللي ما تطلع من نطاق خبرتي
فليش أحتاج أتعاقد مع ناس زيادة أو أطباء؟
مستحيل أن ما تطلع خارج خبرتك
تخصصات طب الأسنان، أنت تتكلم عن تخصصات كثير ودقيقة جدًّا
مو كل شيء مُتقنينه، في تخصصات معينة لازم تكون موجودة
مثلًا تقول: زراعة، حتى الامتيازات السريرية ما تسمح لك تسوي زراعة
التقويم: ما تسمح لك الامتيازات السريرية أنك تسوي تقويم
بس التخصصات الثانية ممكن الامتيازات السريرية تحت إشراف استشاري عندك
فالامتيازات السريرية ما تخليك تسوي أي شيء خلال الدورات؟
لا
ما زال عليها قيود؟
في قيود وفي شيء معين، لأنه دقيق جدًّا والخطأ لا يغتفر
مثلًا ما ودي أخوف، بس أن الخطأ لا يُغتفر
فاهم عليك، زي اللي سوّى لي تقويم
ما أدري أيش اللي صار معك بالتقويم
لا الأمور تمام
بس راح أجاملك، وأقول لك...
الأمور تمام، فمعناته أن أنا بجي أفتح عيادة
فما أقدر أسويها لحالي، أحتاج إلى طباء ثانيين أتعاقد معهم؟
إي، إذا أنت مثلًا عيادة وحدة
أول شيء عنده ثلاثة نماذج
ما أقدر أقول: بسوي عيادة تنظيف أسنان؟
ما في هذا الكلام، في أفكار بس ما تنجح في الغالب
لكن بقول لك: هي ثلاث نماذج للتعاقد مع الأطباء بشكل عام
يا أنه يكون براتب كامل هذا يجيك دوام كامل
أو أنه يكون دوام جزئي
وهذا في الغالب يصلح للموظفين الحكوميين
مثلًا طريق خبير وكذا يجي دوام جزئي، بنسبة ما هو براتب كامل
نسبة من قيمة المراجعة أو العلاج؟
من العلاج، يأخذ منه
كم يأخذ تقريبًا؟
والله تختلف النسبة، ممكن 50-40%
من أي شيء يصرفه العميل عنده؟
أحيانًا يعتمد على اتفاق العيادة معه أن مثلًا بعد المواد أو قبلها
في اتفاق معين
أنها مشاركة أرباح أو مبيعات؟
إي، النوع الثالث، وهو دائمًا اللي أنصح فيه
اللي هو راتب ونسبة، يكون دوام كامل
زي نظام المناديب؟
راتب ونسبة، ما أدري
مناديب المبيعات، يعطيك راتب بحد أدنى، وبعطيك...
لا بس الأطباء يكون راتبهم كذا، ما يكون كذا
حسنًا، فيأخدوا راتب معتبر وفوقه النسبة؟
إي، احنا نتكلم عن ناس متمكنين
متمكن وعنده دوراته وشهاداته العليا، وعنده...
فبذلك هذا يكون عدده قليل، ما هو كثير
لو بجيب، خلنا نقول: بالحد الأدنى من اللي أحتاجه من الأطباء بدوام جزئي
ببدأ عيادة بسيطة، ما أبغى أتفلسف
تحتاج اثنين اقل شيء، إذا عندك خبرة كبيرة
تحتاج مثلًا الزراعة والتقويم
هم التخصصات اللي صعب أنك تطور نفسك عشان...؟
ممكن استشاري تركيبات يكون معك أو كذا
بس في الغالب هم التقويم والزراعة اللي صعب أنك تحصلهم
وبرنامج الامتيازات السريرية
أنت ذكرت أن لازم تكون تحت إشرف استشاري
فتقدر تجيب استشاري بدوام جزئي يشرف عليك؟
إي، زي كذا
ما هي مشكلة؟
ما في مشكلة
مو لازم يكون دوام كامل؟
لا مو شرط
حلو، فهؤلاء ثلاثة، والرواتب تقريبًا كم تكون؟
الدوام الجزئي مثلما قلت لك: يكون نسبة
الدوام الجزئي نسبة حسنًا
إي
بس شلون تقنع طبيب يجي عندك؟
مثلًا يجيك يوم في الأسبوع، تجمع له الحالات كلها يوم في الأسبوع
ويجي يخلصها لك
قصدي الإقناع، لأن أنت متأكد بعد القرار هذا أن في ناس كثير
أنا ما أدري حسب اطلاعاتك
يحاولوا يفتحون أو فتحوا عيادات
بعدين كلهم يروحون، ويكلمون نفس الأشخاص يلا تعالوا اشتغلوا عندنا
بس برضو في نفس الوقت، قلنا: «خبير» ضخ أعداد كبيرة
فما راح يتعب المفروض الواحد أن يلقى خيارات؟
لا ما أتوقع، بس أن دائمًا، كم عمر العيادة؟
هذا يجعله في تحدي أن بجيك، وبتعب نفسي
بس هل عيادتك مشتغلة، وفيها إدارة كويسة؟
أنا ما راح أشتغل معك
وبعدين فجأة أكتشف أنك قاعد تلخبط في اتجاه آخر، والإدارة سيئة
بس هذه مشكلة البيضة والدجاجة، أنا الحين ما أقدر أشغل عيادتي
إلى أن يكون معي اثنين، وهذول يبغوني أكوني مشتغلها
هنا تجي علاقاتك، أنت 5-7 سنوات، أيش سويت؟
والله بنيت علاقات والناس وثقت فيك، وعرفت
واشتغلت في مجمعات كثيرة، عُرِفت أنت
وصار لك اسم، الناس تحترمه
ودائمًا شوف التجارة فيها ثقة، لازم يكونوا يثقون فيك
وثقوا فيك؟ راح يجونك
لكن أنت توك بدأت، أمس متخرج واليوم تفتح
مَن اللي راح يثق أن...
وهذا أحد أسباب أن يكون مشترط موضوع الخبرة 5-7 سنين؟
إي، عشان كذا
تكوّن علاقات
لا بد تكون علاقات، ولازم تعرف، كيف الإدارة؟
وأيش الأخطاء اللي تصير قدام عينك، وكيف يتم معالجتها؟
أنت تتعلم في حلال غيرك، وللا تتعلم في حلالك؟
أنت حلالك على قدك، 700 ألف أو مليون، يلا يخارجك
بذلك لازم مجمعات كبيرة، والأمور هذه
ما هو برضو لما تروح على المجمع أنك تقفل عيادتك وخلاص
لازم تعرف وتكوّن صداقاتك وعلاقاتك، وتقويها
من هنا الناس تبدأ تساعدك
وغير الأطباء عندك...، صح ما قلت لي على الرواتب
لو بشتغل، وأجيب واحد بدوام جزئي
الدوام الجزئي قلنا: نسبة
صح، عفوًا الدوام الجزئي نسبة، أجل أيش اللي كان براتب؟
براتب كامل، أنت لو بتجيبه صعبة
في عيادة ما تقدر تتحمل الرواتب
الرواتب دائمًا تبدأ بأخصائيين إلى استشاريين
تبدأ كدوام كامل يعني تتكلم من 17 إلى فوق الـ35
فبتكون مكلفة بالنسبة لك
جدًّا كعيادة ما تقدر، وعندك مثلًا اثنين لازم يجونك
والكوادر غير الأطباء، عندك ممرضين، تحتاج أحد وللا؟
تحتاج أكيد ممرضك
ممرضة لكل طبيب؟
إذا عيادة واحدة، فأنت وممرضة واحدة بس ما تحتاج أكثر
تحتاج مركز استقبال الاتصال، واستقبال الزوار هي تكون
بس في ثلاثة الحين لازم يبدأون العيادة
إذا مجمّع، لا، في فرق بين مجمّع وعيادة
لا نتكلم على العيادة الواحدة
أنت تقول: لازم طبيبين استشاريين معك
إي، بس يجون أيام في نفس العيادة، هي ممرضة واحدة
مثلًا الدكتور الفلاني راح يجي يوم واحد، وحق الزراعة يوم، والتقويم يوم
فهذه ممرضة، وأيش في بعد كوادر ثانية؟
أكيد راح تحتاج مثلًا واحدة مسؤولة عن المشتريات، ممرضة برضو
ومسؤولة عن التعقيم، ومسؤولة عن النفايات الطبية
عندك عقود أنت وقت التشغيل، خلاص ورّدت الأجهزة
لازم يكون عندك عقدين مهمين، عقد النفايات الطبية، وعقد الحماية من الإشعاع
فهذه شركات تقدمها؟
شركات تقدمها إي
حلو
لازم تكون هذه، وقت التشغيل والتراخيص النهائية يطلبونها منك
ما تقدر تفتح العيادة إلا والعقود هذه موجودة عندك
لازم معك هذه، ومهمة النفايات الطبية لها طرق معينة في التخلص منها
وهذا يدلك أن الدعوة مُنظّمة جدًّا، بس الناس ما هي عارفة
الحماية من الإشعاع، إيش هي؟ هذا المفعل النووي اللي عندكم
لا ما عندنا مفعلات نووية، احنا عندنا الطاقة مسالمة
فالحماية من الإشعاع اللي هو الأشعة
لها أجهزة معينة، وتلبسها الممرضة، ويأخذوها، ويقيسوها
عشان يحموها من الأشعة
لأن كثر التعرض للإشعاع بطريقة غير صحيحة مُضرة لصحتها
ممكن حتى يوقفونها عن العمل
وهي عقود سنوية؟
إي، عقود سنوية
كم تكلف تقريبًا؟
تقريبًا النفايات الطبية ممكن 5000
وهذا ممكن تقريبًا في حدود 2000-2500
ويجون بشكل شهري يشيكون؟
النفايات الطبية بشكل أسبوعي يجي يأخذ النفايات الطبية من عندك
ويعطيك تقرير
وزيارات وزارة الصحة تجي تسألك عن التقارير هذه وينها؟
الحماية من الإشعاع
يجونك بشكل شهري يأخذون الأجهزة حقت التمريض والمسؤولين عن الأشعة
يقيسونها ويتأكدون أنهم ما يتعرضون لأشعة عالية
ويتأكدون، أن غرفة الأشعة البانورامية لا بد أن تكون مرصّصة
وهذه في آخر خطوة
مرصّصة شلون؟
فيها ألواح رصاص، عشان تمنع الأشعة أنها تطلع برة
ويقيسونها هم، يتأكدون أن الأشعة تطلع أو لا؟
في غرفة الأشعة البانورامية
بس في الباب
الباب برضو مرصّص، أنت تشوفه خشب تحسبه، لا مرصص وثقيل
حلو
هذه شركات تجي تسويها
فمُكلف أتصور؟
ما هي مكلفة، تقريبًا بحدود 10-15 ألف
فهم يجون يختبرون أنك مسوي الرصاص بشكل صحيح؟
إي، وأن ما في تسرب إشعاع
وأن المرضى لما يسوون أشعة، ما يتعرض جسمه للأشعة بشكل كبير
في حدود الوضع الطبيعي
فهذا يجي بشكل شهري، فهذه العقود عند التشغيل
في غير الكوادر الطبية، في موظف الاستقبال
إي، موظف الاستقبال، وهو مركز الاتصال
لازم هنا أنت تستعين، إذا أنت بتبدأ وكذا لازم يكون عنده خبرة
ودائمًا أنصح أي مستثمر يبي يوظف أي كوادر إدارية أو طبية
يطلب منها تقرير من التأمينات
ليش؟
ويتأكد أن ما في تنقلات سريعة
لأن عملية التنقل السريع بمَنْشئ المُنشأة
أنت توك رأس مالك ضعيف، وما ودّك تغامر في هذا الاتجاه
ما تبي موظّف استقبال، وبعد أسبوع يمشي
إي، هو جاء مقتنع، وعنده خبرته، أدفع شوي بس ما هو...
يفرق أنه يكون اشتغل في عيادة قبل وللا لا؟
إي، يزيد راتبه
بس أيش الخبرة اللي بتكون عنده؟
يعرف يتعامل، أسميها على خط النار
المراجعين يجون بآلام أحيانًا، فيفقد أعصابه أحيانًا
لا بد أنك تعرف كيف تتعامل معه
وفي ناس لطيفين وفي سيئين
فالخبرة راح تعطيك طريقة التعامل بشكل إيجابي معهم
خلنا نقول كحد أدنى كم شخص تحتاج؟
تقريبًا ثلاثة كوادر مُساندة، بالإضافة لعامل النظافة، راح يكون أربعة
الأطباء أنت واثنين أطباء كدوام جزئي، هذا كحد أدنى
الكوادر المساندة قصدك الممرضات أو الممرضين؟
إي، ممرضتين اثنتين، واحدة معك في العيادة
وواحدة مسؤولة عن الأشعة وعلى المشتريات، ويتم تدريبها بشكل جيد
وعندك الاستقبال يكون واحد، والمنظّف أو المسؤول عن نظافة المكان
هذا أنت تتعاقد مع شركات
ممكن أو أنك تستقدم وتدربه، شيء راجع لك
هؤلاء أربعة، وأنت تكون الطبيب الرئيسي
ومعك اثنين أطباء في التخصصات النادرة اللي هو الزراعة والتقويم
إذا في تركيبات بيكون أفضل، وإذا ما قدرت هذا أقل شيء تحتاجه حاليًا
الآن نجي لنقطة مهمة اللي هي أنت خلاص أسست العيادة
وضبطت أمورك، وجبت لك مقاول وضبطك
وتعاقدت، وخلصت الأمور هذه كلها
عشان تبدأ العيادة رسميًّا في خطوة إضافية ترخيص شيء وللا خلاص؟
أنت في البداية تأخذ ترخيص مبدئي من وزارة الصحة
قبلما تسوي أي شيء؟
قبل لا، خلاص، أنت بتتعاقد، تأخذ عقدك
في البداية لازم تسأل أنت قبل ما تتعاقد مع المالك
الموقع تمام من وزارة الصحة والبلدية، تأخذ شفهيًّا
الأمور تمام؟ حسنًا تتعاقد وتأخذ عقدك
وتأخذ ترخيصك المبدئي من وزاة الصحة
وبعد ذلك تأخذ الترخيص المبدئي من البلدية، وتخلص أمورك
بعدين البلدية يعطوك الترخيص النهائي
وعندك شيء اسمه الدفاع المدني
لازم شركة خاصة للدفاع المدني عشان يعطوك الترخيص
وعندك بعدها لازم يكون مكتمل عنده رخصة إتمام بناء، المالك
إذا ما عنده هذا الشيء راح تتوهق
بس هذا يمكن لحاله، هو الموضوع هذا ينطبق على جميع المكاتب
بغض النظرة عن عيادة أسنان أو غيره
بس أن تعرف بعضهم ما عنده الخبرة هذه
فالمعلومة مهمة بالنسبة له، لازم إتمام البناء تكون عنده
عند المبنى أصلًا؟
عند المبنى، وبرضو إذا في شهادة دفاع مدني كويسة، هذه تساعد
خاصة في المجمعات، لأنك راح تقلل جزء كبير
مضخات الدفاع المدني وكذا، عند المجمعات هذا شرط أساسي
فراح توفر عليك من القيمة يمكن 60-80 ألف
فبالنسبة للعيادة برضو كذلك لا بد يكون
إذا فيه ترخيص الدفاع المدني راح يسهل عليك أمور كثيرة
فتخلص ترخيص الدفاع المدني والبلدية
بعدها ترجع للصحة يعطوك الترخيص النهائي
فهذا الترخيص النهائي هو نفس الانطلاق الحين
خلاص أنت الآن الترخيص النهائي يتطلب منك العقود اللي ذكرتها
النفايات الطبية والحماية من الإشعاع، وبعدين تنطلق
مجرد ما تجيب الترخيص النهائي خلاص أنت جاهز الآن تستقبل المراجعين
لازم أنت قبل أن تصل إلى هذه النقطة مرتب الكوادر معك
ومدربهم، إذا ما عنده خبرة لازم تدربه
تسوي شيء اسمه الافتتاح التجريبي
أول شهر أو شهرين حسنًا أمورنا تمام؟ تنطق
بس الترخيص النهايي يتطلب وجود الكوادر هؤلاء؟
يتطلب إذا أنت مجمع أو عيادة، إذا عيادة لا أنت كافي
لكن إذا مجمع في نقطة إضافية، لازم يكون عندك أخصائي أول
خلها هذه بنيجيها بنقطة المجمعات
بس الآن خلاص أنا فتحت عيادتي ومعي الترخيص، والأمور كلها تمام
بدأت الافتتاح التجريبي، ومن أين أجيب العملاء، وشلون أسوق لعيادتي؟
تبدأ هنا هل عندك خبرة تسويقية أو لا؟
أنت المفترض خلال 5-7 سنوات اللي اشتغلت فيها في القطاع الخاص
وزارة المواد البشرية مشكورة تقدم لك دورات مجانية
في الثقافة العمالية، والتسويق الرقمي
قاعدة تقدم لك دورات مجانية
للموظف في القطاع الخاص، للسعودي مجاني
ما تدفع ريال، فأنت ادخل الدورات هذه، وخُذ الخبرات اللازمة
لأن هذا يعتبر استثمار في نفسك
أفضل من أنك بعدين تروح تجيب شركة تسوق لك
قد تكون أصلًا ما هي بناجحة
لأنك مسبقًا، نرجع لنقطة أن الوقت هو المال
فبذلك أنت محسوب عليك إيجار وكودر ورواتب
فأنت لك خيارين يا أن يكون عندك خبرة، وأخذت هذا الطريق
خبرة تسويقية في مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي، والأمور هذه
أو أنك تجيب شركة تسويق، وتبدأ تسوق لك
فمن هنا يبدأ يجي العملاء، لوحاتك وأمورك ومعارفك والمرضى
فبذلك راح شوي شوي تنطلق
ومثلما قلت لك: سلاحك هو حاجتين، الصدق والأمانة
هذه راح توصلك بأسرع ما يمكن، بالإضافة لقدرتك
القدرة الطبية وقدرة التعامل
ومهارة التواصل إذا عالية عندك انتهى الموضوع
والناس هم اللي راح يجيبون لك ناس أكثر
راح يجيبون لك على طول سريعين
لأن يقول لك: الأطباء المتمكنين واللي عندهم مهارة التواصل جدًّا قليل
أنا ما أدري قبل فترة شفت في اتجاه لعيادات الأسنان
أنهم يطلعون إعلانات في سناب، تجيهم فترة كذا
يعلنون سبعين عيادة ويحطون ألف سناب
وتكون واحدة هي اللي تطلع تتكلم في الإعلان
أنا ما أدري أيش الفكرة من الموضوع
هذه مثل فكرة عروض الشتاء والصيف
في عروض اسمها عروض الشتاء والصيف
وتعال الخصم 50%
لا، ما ينفع الكلام هذا
ليش؟
ما أنت قاعد تبيع ملابس
أنت تقدم خدمة طبية حتى لو هو إعلانك لازم يكون بشكل احترافي أفضل
هذا وجهة نظري الشخصية، ما هو بهذا الشكل
لابد أنك أول حاجة تزن الأمور وتعرف
مثلًا احنا مقبلين الأيام الجاية، إن شاء الله، إن الله أحيانا، على اليوم الوطني
اليوم الوطني كلنا حتى لو نصل لسعر التكلفة عادي، فهو احتفال
فممكن توصل
لكن ما تجيني تقول: عروض شتاء وصيف وعيد، ما هي ملابس
شو المشكلة، في النهاية ما تشوفها تسويق؟ هي تجيب لك ناس زيادة
كثرة العروض، أنت تقدم خدمة طبية إنسانية
فلما أنت تربطها بالعروض، فكأنك تتكلم بالمادة أكثر
هذا وجهة نظري الشخصية
أنا أفضل أن لا، تكلم عن الخدمة والتثقيف الصحي
وعن خدماتك اللي تقدمها، وجودة علاجك اللي تقدمه والتعقيم
هذه الأمور، وعن تجربة مميزة للمراجع
هذا التسويق الحقيقي اللي يكون أساسه ثابت
ما تشوف العيادات هذه ساهمت أن العميل يتوجه للأرخص
بدل ما يروح للأجود؟
الأرخص أفضل من الأجود؟ سأعلمك حاجة أنت عندك نوعين من العملاء
تصنيف برضو شخصي
عميل جاءك من باب العيادة، وعميل جاءك من عوائل
عوائل؟
عوائل، أن أنت مثلًا والله أخوي مشهور الدبيان
عائلة الدبيان تعرف على دكتور فهد، ودكتور فهد هو دكتور العائلة
الآن في تخصصات جديدة اللي التخصصات الصحية
اسمها طب أسنان الأسرة
فهذا المفهوم هو المفهوم الحقيقي في أرض الواقع
بالنسبة اللي يجيك من باب العيادة فيه تحديات كبيرة
أنها أول شيء لازم تقنعه أنك طبيب مُخلص
وتقدم له كل خيارات العلاج، ما هو بتختارها لنفسك أنت
مع نسب النجاح، وللمراجع الحق أن يختار
أن تعرض الخيارات وهو يختار
مع نصيحتك أكيد ومشورتك الطبية، أنت تعاونه وتساعده
فهو صعب، المراجع اللي يجي من مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
أنت قاعد تبيع عليه فعليًّا
أنت تتعب معه كثير، وتبذل المجهود مرتين
لكن اللي يجيك عن طريق العوائل
والله مشهور وصى أخوه أن دكتور فهد مرة ممتاز، روح له
لما يجيني أخوك، الله يحفظه، يجيني وهو مقتنع أن دكتور فهد ممتاز
ومسبقًا عارف أنه طبيب وعنده قدرة، فما راح يتعبك
فأنت في بداياتك راح تكون مع المراجع هذا اللي يجي من باب العيادة
لحد ما تكوّن لك قاعدة العوائل اللي تؤمن فيك
أو حتى الأصدقاء
أو الأصدقاء أو كذا، لحد ما تصير أنت عندك العوائل
مجرد العوائل خلاص أنت أمورك
جدولك يقفل أسبوعين أو ثلاثة أو شهر لقدام
أفهم منك أن هذا اللي يجي عن طريق مثلًا العروض
مُتعب أكثر حتى من اللي يجيك...
مُتعب، فما بالك تجيب...
يقعد يكاسرك بدل ما...
ممكن هذه واحدة من الأشياء، وين مهارة التواصل؟
كيف تقنعه أنك قاعد تعطيه جودة وخدمة كويسة؟
هو الأساس، أنت لازم تقنع المراجع
هو جاءك ويبحث عن خدمة
وفي مسار آخر أشوف الأطباء بشكل عام أو بعض الأطباء يتبعونه
اللي يسألون مشاهير مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
اللي يسوي حساب سناب، ويتكلم عن الأمور هذه أو يروّج أو أيًّا كان
أنا مع أي حساب في مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي ينشر التثقيف الصحي، انطلق
أنت قاعد تحسب الأجر، وهذا شيء إيجابي
وبرضو إذا الناس عرفوك يا هلا ومرحبًا، لا بأس
لكن مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي بشكل غير صحيح أو بشكل تشكيك
قبل فترة، مثلًا قرأت أن يقول: تصريفة طبيب الأسنان
يقول: أو غسول الفم استخدمه، هذه تصريفة، هذا الكلام...
تصريفة شلون؟
يقول: أن أكبر تصريفة أو كذبة في طب الأسنان
يقول لك: عندك التهاب استخدم غسول الفم
هذه أراها غير صحيحة، أول شيء التشكيك في الذمم
هذه قصدك طبيب قالها؟
إي، وهو خارج السعودية
فأنت ما تقدر تدخل في الذمم، ولا تشكك فيها
فغير مُحبب أنك تبحث عن اتجاه بالطريقة هذه
تحاول تثير الجدل
إثارة الجدل، خاصة الناس عندهم رُهاب وخوف
وعندهم تجارب أحيانًا قد تكون سيئة في عيادات الأسنان
فلما يسمع الكلام هذا خلاص طلع الطبيب برضو كاذب
أنت خربت الموضوع كامل، هذا غير صحيح
وهذا أصلًا كتصريفة إذا هي تصرفات فردية، فهي تصرفات فردية
لا يُؤخذ فيها من مجتمع طب الأسنان بشكله الكامل
والتعميم دائمًا لغة غير صحيحة
لغة الجهلاء، عليك فيهم، ما عليك
قد شفت أي عيادات مثلًا تُعلن عن طريق مشاهير؟
الإعلانات في البداية أنت تحتاج فقط كناشئ
هي الشعلة اللي راح تُولع لك
لكن إذا اعتمادك دائمًا على الإعلانات، أنت عندك مشكلة
وخدمتك غير جيدة، في إشكالية
الصدق في صعوبة عندكم برضو أن ما تقدر تميز نفسك بالإعلان
أقدر مثلًا لو أنا شركة، خلنا نقول شركة اتصالات
شركة الاتصالات أقدر أقول: هذه الباقة فيها كذا، وتختلف عن منافسي
أنتم كلكم تسوون نفس الشيء من برة
فما تقدر تروج إلا بالخصومات فعليًّا
لا، تجربة العميل ما بعد الخدمة، هذه تراها مفقودة تمامًا
كيف؟
أنت...
تعطي ضمان؟
لا، مثلًا بعد الخدمة اتصل عليه واطمئن عليه، وتشوف أيش صار له
إذا هو مثلًا مسوي عملية جراحية كبيرة، وللا مسوي شيء عندك
كان بألم شديد وجاءك
فخدمة ما بعد الخدمة أو ما بعد العملية الطبية، هذه مفقودة
سويت الخدمة، ومع السلامة
بس ما تقدر تحطها في إعلان
ويقولون الناس: أوف، والله هؤلاء عندهم؟
الإعلان أنت تحتاجه مبدئيًّا
اللي يعتمد على الإعلان بشكل دائم هذا عنده مشكلة
في الاحتفاظ بالمراجع
لازم تراجع نفسك، وسياساتك الداخلية، عندك إشكالية
هي المفروض، يعني أنت ستة شهور أو سنة، وخلاص توقف عنها
حلو، لأنك إذا قدرت تحافظ على المراجعين، المفروض هم يجيبون غيرهم
خلاص أنت نمّيت العوائل اللي احنا نتكلم عنها
من هنا أنت بدأت تنطلق
كلمة المراجع هي أصدق شيء، دعاية المراجع نفسه
هي أصدق وأسهل شيء، وتجيب لك نوعية ممتازة من المراجعين
هذه مرة مهمة
أيش الفرق أنت ذكرت قبل شوي نقطة عن المجمعات؟
أيش تفرق المجمعات؟
كاشتراطات
مثلًا مستثمر أو طبيب، ما شاء الله، الله فتحها عليك
هو مسموح لك كمستثمر غير طبيب
ومسموح لك كطبيب أنك تفتح كمجمع، هنا التحديات تكبر
نتكلم أولاً عن عيادة والأخطاء محفوفة، وتلحقها بدري
وتقدر تتلافى أمور كثيرة، والهدر عندك قليل
والتكلفة التشغيلية قليلة، والتحديات أقل
الهدر من وين يجي؟
الهدر ممكن تجي مثلًا مواد طلبتها، وانتهى تاريخها، ولازم تتخلص منها
فيُعتبر هدر، أنت ما تدري، أنت اشتريت حشوات
المراجع جاءني أو ما جاء، استخدمتها أو ما استخدمها، وصار هدر
انتهى تاريخها
كم صلاحيتها؟
أحيانًا تستمر سنة أو سنتين أو ثلاثة
يعتمد على المورد، أيش عنده في البضاعة؟
ممكن أحيانًا يقول: عندي ستة شهور، تبغاه؟
أرخص هذيك خذها
ما في أرخص، يبيعها لك بنفس السعر
فأنت لازم تكون ذهيًّا أن لا المورد عندك كذا، ببحث عن موزعين
الموزع ممكن عنده أطول
فلا بد أنك تبحث عن الأمور هذه
بتكون عندك اسمها
حلو فالمجمعات...
اسمها حسن التدبير لازم تكون عندك، هذه مهارات ما تُدرّس في الجامعات
فالمجمعات يمكن نسبة الخطأ أكبر، والعيادات أكبر
إي، أكبر وموارد بشرية أكثر
في اشتراطات إضافية حتى؟
في اشتراطات إضافية، لازم يكون عندك أخصائي أول
في تخصص طب الأسنان، هذا واحد
المدير الطبي لازم يكون طبيب سعودي
المدير الإداري لازم يكون سعودي ومعه بكالوريس في أي تخصص
طبي أو غير طبي، ما يهم
لازم يكون عندك نسبة السَّعودة في الأطباء
وهذه مشكورة وزارة المواد البشرية تحاول أن تدخل حديثي التخرج
في القطاع الخاص وأنهم يأخذوا هذه الخبرة
فألزموهم بـ30% نسبة جدًّا ضخمة
أن 30% من الأطباء عندك لازم يكونوا سعوديين
فهذا جزء من المجمعات والاشتراطات العامة
وبرضو تأييد الكوادر، ما يعطونه...
هذا من الحوافز برضو اللي قدمتها وزارة الصحة
غير السعودي الموجودين في...
أيش هو تأييد الكوادر؟
أنت لما تجي خاصةً، عندك الكوادر السعودية، والغير سعودية
السعودي راح تتفق معه داخل البلد
غير السعودي راح تبحث في البلدان العربية والأجنبية
عن طبيب في التخصص هذا
عشان تأخذ الفيزا، لازم يكون عندك شيء اسمه تأييد الكوادر
عشان تطلع الفيزا هذه، تسمح لك وزارة الموارد البشرية
يعطون اعتماد على الطبيب هذا ودراسته
لا، أن حسنًا هذه المُنشأة تستحق مثلًا خمسة أو سبعة فيز زي كذا
حلو
الفيز هذه مكتوب فيها التخصص
هم عندهم مربوطين في هيئة التخصصات الصحية
في شغل جبار، بس المشكلة اللي يراها من الخارج يحسب أن...
لكن الشغل مرة احترافي
مربوطين بهيئة التخصصات الصحية
ويعرفوا وين التخصصات اللي صار فيها امتلاء من السعوديين
فيُمنع عليك، مثلًا تقول: أبغى تركيبات، يقول لك: ممنوع
عندنا كفاية
عندنا كفاية، وروح ابحث عنهم
ففي تأييد، ومحاولة إدخال الشباب السعودي والنهضة فيه
لأن هو الأساس والاستثمار
هو راح يبدأ طبيب الآن، بكرة راح يصير مالك
ويصير عنده عيادات ومجمعات
نأخذ مثال حبيبي، الله يوفقه
هو أحد الناس اللي دخلوا في القطاع الخاص، والآن عنده سلاسل كبيرة
فهذه هي الفكرة، أن ندخله الآن، ويأخذ الخبرة، وينجح وينطلق
حلو، والاختلاف في التكاليف ما بين...
التكاليف التشغيلية
المجمع والعيادة، أن غير مسألة المساحة والعيادات أكثر
صحيح
فنفس التكاليف تكبر
وفي اشترطات على كوادر إضافية
صحيح
هؤلاء كلهم لازم يكونون دوام كامل؟
صحيح، لازم يكون دوام كامل
حلو، فهي ارتفاع في التكاليف؟
تضرب نفس تكاليف العيادة بـ 5 أو 6؟
مبالغ ضخمة
حسب...
عشان كذا نقول: تكلفة إنشاء مجمع
ثلاثة عيادات ممكن أن يصل إلى 300-400
مبلغ ضخم مو بسيط
وين عقدك، طويل الأمد وللا قصير الأمد؟
لازم تربط أمورك وتعرف، ما هي استأجر ويلا افتح
الناس عشان تعرفك يبغى لك سنتين أو ثلاثة
كل هذا وما تكلمنا على جانب الإيرادات الحين
كم هامش الربح لو بتحسبها اليوم جاءك مريض؟
أول شيء كيف تسعر أساسًا المرضى؟
هل في سعر متعارف عليه، تقوله لكل مراجع؟
أو خلنا نقول: الحشوة كذا، وخلع العصب كذا، هل في أسعار موحدة؟
هل تقدر تحط أنت الطبيب تقول: تكاليفي عالية
بصقع السعر فوق، لأن علي طلب؟
شلون موضوع التسعير، والتحكم في السعر؟
أنت لازم أول شيء تدرس السوق
لازم تصير ابن سوق، اسمها ابن سوق
لازم تدرس السوق، وتعرف العيادات، وأيش تقدم وتسعيرتها؟
تعرف موقعك، وين أنت؟
خدماتك أيش اللي تقدمها، هل هي خدمات مُخملية؟
إيه أو بي أو سي لازم تحدد
هذه التصنيفات متعارف عليها وللا؟
لا، أنت لازم تعرف في عيادات قائمة أسعارها مرة نازلة
وفي عيادات متوسطة، وعيادات مرتفعة جدًّا
أنت وين خدماتك؟
أيش تشبه من السوق؟
لازم تعرف منافسك، مَن هو؟
منافسي مثلًا العيادات المتدنية الدخل مثلًا
متوسطة الدخل أو متوسطة الخدمة أو عالية الخدمة
لازم تحدد
فبناءً عليه أنت ‫تتشابه معهم، ولازم تكون أنت منافس في السعر والخدمة
‫لازم تصير منافس في السعر والخدمة مثل قطاع المقاهي
‫لازم تصير مُنافس السعر والخدمة، ‫هذا نفس الشيء
‫بس عادةً لو بتأخذها على كل فئة
كيف تكون هوامش الربح؟ ‫لو بنحسبها على المراجعة
‫أنت لو تتكلم عن هوامش الربح تكاد تنعدم في البدايات
ليش؟
لأن أنت عندك التكلفة التشغيلية الأساسية
الإيجار مدفوع، في مرضى أو لا
الرواتب مدفوعة، في مراجع ولا لا
الكهرباء، والرسوم المطلوبة منك للجهات الحكومية مدفوعة
أنت لازم تعرف، أنت عندك شيء
بس أن كلما اشتغلت أكثر كلما قدرت تغطي هذا الحد الأدنى
وقدرت تطلع فوقه
فما أقدر أقول لك: أن هامش الربح كذا
وعندك التكفة التشغيلية كم؟ لازم تعرفها
هل هي عيادة أو مجمع، تفرق؟ والمجمع كم عيادة؟
فهي زي أي خدمة ثانية، أنت تحتاج تغطي التكاليف
وأنت وشطارتك تقدر ترفع ربحك أو...
إي، إذا الناس عرفوك، وصار عندك خدمة مميزة
راح تصير أنت تطلع، ويصير وقتك الثماني ساعات اللي تقضيها
عندك فيها مرضى، ما عندك وقت فاضي
لكن إذا أنا أشوف مراجع واحد في اليوم
صح
أو أشوف ثمانية مراجعين، تفرق
بس موضوع الأسعار تحط على مزاجك؟
لا، لازم تعرف المنافسين
أنت عرفت المنافسين، الحين شفت أن ناس يسون مثلًا أعطني إجراء معين
حشو مثلًا، ناس يسوونها بـ200 وناس بـ300 وناس بـ400
في شيء يحكم الموضوع هذا، وللا بس خلاص شوف مين يشبهك؟
لا، الحشوات كم نوع؟ كثير
كلها حشوات بيضاء بس كثير أنواعها
في نوع أمريكي نوعيته ممتاز، وفي نوع ألماني، وكوري وروسي، كثير
ما في شيء، مع فارق التشبيه، لا تأخذها بشكل شخصي
لازم تأخذ، عشان بس ما أخذها بشكل شخصي
لأني قاعد ألف وأدور حول النقطة هذه، ما كنت أبي أسألك
أقول: في شيء زي الحلاقين حاطين أسعار الوزارة لكم
أن هذه ما تقدر تتجاوزها؟
لا، أنت لازم تسوي شيء، بوصلك المرحلة هذه
مع أنه بفارق التشبيه، أنا بقوم ترى
أخذتها شخصية
في وجه شبه ثاني
أنا جاي أمثّل طب الأسنان
الأطباء حتى عندهم حركة اللي يشوف أسنانك
إذا أول مرة، يقول: يا أخي مين سوى لك الشغل هذا؟
ما يعجبه دائمًا
إي، بالضبط ما يعجبه
بس في شيء من الوزارة مثلًا الحشوة هذا أعلى شيء
اسمع مني، أنت لما تحدد
لازم تدرس المنافس بعدين تقدم قائمة أسعارك للقطاع الخاص
القطاع الخاص يعتمد لك إياه، اللي هو إدارة القطاع الخاص
في الشؤون الصحية اللي تتبع لها المنطقة
يختمون لك عليها، ولازم تُعرض في مكان بارز على الاستقبال
فما تقدر تضعها على كيفك؟
لا خلاص أُعتمدت أسعارك
أنت أسعارك حطيتها بناءً على دراسة السوق
بس هم ما يفرق معهم، هل هو بـ100 أو 500؟
لا، إذا كان مرة، أكيد أن راح يصير...
الإشكالية عندك إذا مثلًا أنت حددتها بـ200 ورحت سويتها بـ400
إي، بس هم ما...
هذا اللي يفرق معهم كثير
بس ما طلبوا يعتمدونها، إلا إذا في مشكلة صارت، فيبغون يحكمون
أنت لو تكتب بألف ما أحد جايك
أنت لازم تكون واقعي، لا تصير
أنت لازم تدرس السوق ولا تأخذها عباطة
أو بحطها ألف أو ألفين، وراح يجوني ويدفعوا 2000
أيش الاسم الكبير اللي راح يجي يدفع لك 2000 وأنت توك داخل؟
صح
أنت لازم تعرف منافسك مَن هو، وأيش ‫قائمة أسعاره؟
‫بناءً عليه تحدد، وممكن حتى تنزل عنه
‫لازم أنت تصير منافس له في السعر والخدمة
بعدين لما تحط قائمة أسعارك تروح تعتمدها من وزارة الصحة
هنا يا ويلك تتعداها
خلاص أُقرت، تعرضها بمكان بارز
يشتكي المراجع أنك تعديتها، الحشوة عندك بـ200 وسويتها بـ300
تتحمل جزاءك
وأساسًا كيف تقدر تدير، على سيرة أن المراجع يشتكي
شلون تدير تجربة المراجعين؟
شلون تتأكد مثلًا أن العميل هذا راضي عن الخدمة المقدمة؟
لأن عندكم مشكلة، أن المشاكل تبين بعد ستة شهر أو سنة
ومستحيل تقعد تتابع مع العميل كل الفترات هذه
فهل في إجراء معين عشان تقدر تحكم الجودة في العيادة عندك؟
أو أي طبيب أن يحكم الجودة في العيادات الثانية
اللي الأطباء يشتغلون معه فيها، وللا أنه يشد حيله، ويدعي ربه؟
لا، دائمًا هنا تجي التحديات التشغيلية هذه اسمها
الجودة إذا أنت ما ضبطتها راح ترجع للعلامة التجارية حقك على اسمك كمركز
طبيب في فترة تعاقد، يستمر معك وللا يمشي، أنت كمركز
وللا هو المفترض أن الطبيب عنده تأمين ضد الأخطاء الطبية
مثل السيارات
لو ارتكب خطأ طبي، شركة التأمين تعوض هذا المتضرر
إذا ثبت أنه خطأ طبي
بس أنت برضو تخاف على سمعتك أكثر من...
بس أن هذه أنت ما ودّك توصلها
أنك تقول: خلاص هي بين الطبيب والمراجع، وأنا مالي دخل
لا، الطبيب لو انتهى عقده؛ مشى
بس الإرث اللي حقّقه ما بين جودة أو سوء جودة، أنت اللي راح تأخذه
صح
فبذلك لا بد أنك تكون سريع وفعال في اتخاذ الإجراء، لازم تتابع
هنا عشان كذا لو تقل لي، مثلًا نأخذ السؤال بطريقة أخرى
تنصح مستثمر غير طبيب أن يدخل السوق الآن في 2023 أو أطباء فقط؟
أقول لك: الغير طبيب صعب عليه أن يعرف الجودة
فبذلك أنت راح يكون معيارك شيء واحد، كم دخل الطبيب عندي؟
وبعضهم يمثّلك أحلى تمثيل، أن أنا طبيب شاطر ودخلي كويس
وأنت تُغر فيه، إي والله والناس تحبه
نجي من ضمن الـ 50% اللي قلناهم عندهم مهارة تواصل
بس ما عنده المهارات الطبية الكافية أو المهارات المميزة
فبذلك بعد فترة تبين الأخطاء العلاجية، فتكتشف متأخر هذه الإشكالية
فالعب في العلامة التجارية حقتك
فلا بد أنك تكون طبيب، وعارف أيش المعيار
بس أنت شلون تحكم الجودة فعليًّا؟
أن التركيبات تكون ثابتة صح، وما فيها فراغات
وعلاج العصب يكون واصل لذروة السن
هذا أنت من نفسك، بس إذا أنت جايب الاثنين اللي معك عشان تفتح عيادة؟
أنت لازم عقودك تكون محددة معهم
في جودة وعندي كذا، ومعايير الجودة عندي كذا
وتراها كذا، وفيها خصومات تتحملها
الله يعطيك العافية، لإعادة العلاج لو صار في إشكالية عندي
أنت لازم تحمي العلامة التجارية حقتك
حسنًا، فهذه تكون فيها زي القواعد الإرشادية أو المعايير؟
إي، لازم تشتغل، هذه نتيجة خبرة الـ5-7 سنوات
هذه كثير من العيادات تطبقها؟
لا مو كثير للأمانة
بس ضروري يكون في معايير؟
لازم يكون في
يحاسب الطبيب
الآن الطبيب مثلما قلت لك: المراجع وعيه جدًّا عالي، فصار فاهم وعارف
فبذلك أنت لازم تلعب على موضوع الجودة، ما تلعب على موضوع العدد
هذا انتهى زمنه، ما هو بهذا الوقت
اليوم السوق تعتقد أن يتّسع لعدد كبير من العيادات الإضافية؟
جدًّا، وأنا أقول دائمًا: في لوحات كثير، بس أطباء مُتمكنين قليل
والله أقولها وأنا متأكد ومسؤول عن هذه الكلمة
الأطباء المتمكنين اللي عليهم الكلام قليل
اللوح؟ في لوحات كثيرة، امشي في الشارع تلاقي لوحات كثير
فتختلف الأمور
أنا أشوف أن الآن الوقت فيه شح كبير للأطباء المتميزين
أيش المشكلة تعتقد؟
ما هو المشكلة هي، هي بس مثلما قلت
زمان كنا نتمنى كلنا وظائف حكومية
الآن بدأنا ندخل القطاع الخاص، كأطباء أسنان أتكلم
بذلك بدأنا تونا نتعرف على القطاع الخاص، حديثي التعرف
ما تعتقد الآن القطاع الخاص مسيطر عليه؟
المجمعات الضخمة اللي تتبع للشركات الكبرى؟
فيصير صعب أنك لحالك تجي تنافس؟
أنا أقول: لا، مستحيل أن أحد يسيطر على أطباء الأسنان، لأن هي خدمة
وهي مثل الرسام، أنت ترسم وفي لوحات تُباع بمئات الملايين
وفي لوحة بخمسة ريال
الرسام يفرق معه ومهارة، ليش؟ هذا رسام وهذا رسام
لا، هذا رسام عليه كلام، وهذا رسام...
فالطبيب لا بد يكون عنده المهارة القوية ليقدر ينافس فيها
قصدك ما هو منتج أن الشركة تجي تصنعه بكميات كبيرة وتبيع
إي، ما تقدر تبيع
لأنه حرفة في النهاية
أنا هنا أجيب، مع أن هذه توصية متواضعة مني
ولكن أرى أنها لها، في شُح في عمليات شركات متخصصة
تؤسس وتساعد في التشغيل
أنا أتمنى أن هذا النموذج يكون موجود، وهو غير موجود
والمنافسة فيه صفر
وأنا هنا أشوف وأقترح هذا الاقتراح على شركة الصحة القابضة
وعلى صندوق الاستثمارات العامة
لأنه هامش الربح فيه عالي
أن أنا أجيك كطبيب، وأعطيك المبلغ وأن تسوي لي كل شيء؟
لا، مو مبلغ، أنا أسس لك
الآن شفت التحديات قديش كبيرة؟
كطبيب درس لسبع سنين من عمره
هذا يحتاج له سبع سنين ثانية عشان يفهمها
فبذلك أنت ممكن تطلب منهم خبرة معينة
مثلًا ثلاث أو خمس أو سبع سنوات
وتسوي له مقابلة وتتأكد منه
وبعدين خلاص أنا أجي، وأنشئ لك العيادة، وأساعدك في التشغيل
وأخذ منك هامش ربح، وأنت مسؤول عن خسارتك، تقدم أهلًا وسهلًا
بس أيش فرقها بتكون عن نظام المجمعات؟
هذه تساعد على الموضوع
لا، أنت تصير مسؤول عن عيادتك، مشهور مسوؤل عن عيادته كاملة
بس مو المجمعات يسوون كذا الحين؟
لا، أنا أتكلم عن العيادات، ممكن العيادات هذه تنجح فيها مرة كثير
قصدك يسوون لك مكتب صغير؟
عيادة وشقة كذا، ويجهزوها لك، ويؤسسون لك فيها كل حاجة
ويوردون لك فيها الأجهزة والمواد
ويساعدونك في اختيار الكوادر، ويشغلون لك التشغيل، ويساعدونك إشرافيًّا
وأنت تنطلق
ممكن تكون للأطباء المتميزين حافز، على الأقل هذه الفئة
جدًّا ممتازة، هذه تسرّع عملية الدخول في السوق
لأن فيه خوف وحذر ورأس مال يحتاج، ففيه تخوّف
لكن هذه راح تعطيه جراءة أكثر
أتمنى هذا النموذج أن يدخل سواءً من الشركات الحكومية أو شبة حكومية
أو حتى القطاع الخاص بشكل عام، هذا النموذج أشوفه ناجح، وغير موجود
لو أسألكم أيش أبرز ثلاث مشاكل يواجهوها عادةً في عياداتهم
أو في إدارة العيادة؟
في إدارة العيادة، ثلاث مشاكل أساسية
هي عدم الوصول للجودة إلى أقصى حد ممكن، هذا تحدي مرة كبير
وتحدي التسرب الوظيفي وإدارة الكوادر البشرية
أنت مطلوب منك مهارات كبيرة
منها كأنك تفهم في الموارد البشرية وتكنولوجيا المعلومات
عندك مهارات كثير لازم يكون عندك أقل شيء خلفية فيها أو مَن يساعدك فيها
كذلك عمليات التفاوض
أنا واحدة من مواقف أذكرها
كان وصلني فيها خبر أن في عيادة تعاقدت مع شركة مواد تبييض
قيمة المادة هي تقريبًا كان 1000، وقال: نعطيك إياها بـ 800
عرض، بس تشتري منّا بـ 30 ألف
ونعطيك معها جهاز هدية، ونعطيك، انبسط صاحب العيادة ووقع معهم
بس نسى أن لها تاريخ انتهاء
هل تقدر تخلص الكمية هذه خلال تاريخ الانتهاء هذا؟
هنا لا بد يصير عندك مهارات التفاوض، في أخطاء تصير أحيانًا
بس الأخطاء، الخبرة تقلل منها
حلو، أنا ودي أختم معك بنقطة
اللي لها يمكن ما يكون علاقة مباشرة بالعمل التجاري
بالأمس تقول: الحين فيه فرصة كبيرة السوق
وفي تنظيم الآن يسمح للأطباء السعوديين أنهم يشغلوا عياداتهم
أو يشتغلوا في القطاع الخاص
بس بنفس الوقت من فترة لفترة تسمع عن بطالة الأطباء السعوديين
ومو لاقين فرص ومو لاقين، فأيش اللي صاير هنا؟
أحس في شيء، الأمور مو راكبة على بعض
ما هي راكبة صحيح
هنا برضو لو نشوف الجهود المبذولة مثلًا في هيئة التخصصات الصحية
هيئة التخصصات الصحية، مشكورة قدمت...
لأن «البورد السعودي» كان في أغلب تخصصاته أربع سنوات
قللوه إلى ثلاث سنوات مع الحفاظ على مخرجات التعليم، وجودتها
بحيث أنه يواكبوه لأن في أعداد كبيرة تدخل القطاع الخاص
بالإضافة برضو إلى أن الطبيب خلال الفترة هذه يدفعون راتبه وزارة الصحة
خلال التدريب يشجعونه على أنه يطور من نفسه، وينطلق
كل هذه عوامل تُحفّز
الإشكالية هي ترجع للأطباء العامين
هي الإشكالية أن البطالة تخص في الغالب، الأطباء العامين
الطبيب العام يكون أخذ ست سنوات في دراسة المرحلة الجامعية
ويصل لسنة الامتياز مُنهك
فبعضهم يأخذ راحة أو بعضهم ما يعرف يستغل سنة الامتياز بشكل...
السر كله في سنة الامتياز
أنت لو قدرت أنك تطور من نفسك في سنة الامتياز
لأنها هي تسمح لك تدخل المستشفيات الحكومية والمرجعية
وتحت إشراف استشاريين ومُتمكنين
حاول أن تطور نفسك في علاج العصاب والخلع، شد الهمة شوي
هذه أهم سنة، هذه اللي تصقلك
الإشكالية أنهم يتخرجون بالمهارات الطبية...
أنت عندك نوعين
اللي يجيب المريض بنسبة كبيرة قد تكون 60% أحيانًا هو الألم
جاءه ألم قوي واتجه للعيادة، لما يجي بالألم، أيش سببه؟
هو إما علاج عصب أو يحتاج خلع
فأنت لازم الاثنتين هذه مُتقنها، أقل شيء
وهذه هي جواز سفرك اللي راح يدخلك العيادات الخاصة
إلى أن يكون معك المهارات الطبية اللازمة، ومُتقنها بشكل كبير
ما أخذت الأساسيات فقط، أنت متقدم ومتطور فيها
هذا الطبيب العام ما يقدر يسويها؟
المشكلة الجامعة تعلمك الأساسيات
الأشياء الأساسية
الأشياء الأساسية، دلة
لكن الدائري تتعلمه في الامتياز
فإذا تعلمت في الامتياز، قدرت تدخل القطاع الخاص
والقطاع الخاص يقدر يتبناك في موضوع آخر
أطور منك مثلًا في إدارة الوقت، وفي حسن التدبير، وتعاملك مع المريض
هذه يقدر القطاع الخاص يتبناك فيها
لكن إذا أنت ما عندك المهارات الطبية المتقدمة
مثلًا علاج العصب والخلع، أنت ما راح تكون مفيد كثير
أنت بتصير عبء على العيادة
تتوقع هذا ساهم بموضوع البطالة؟
ساهم بنسبة كبيرة، وهنا الإشكالية
أنا هنا أدعو خاصةً الآن الجامعات مثلًا في سنة الامتياز سووا دورات تدريبية
حتى لو بفلوس، خارج أوقات العمل
سووا دورات تدريبية، واحرص عى أنه يتطور في علاج العصب والخلع
أو أنه خلال تدريبه في الامتياز احرص عليه في هذه الأشياء
أن تكون عنده مثلًا متطلبات معينة يخلصها
هنا هو راح ينطلق للقطاع الخاص بكل قوة
لكن لما يكون هو فاقد المهارات الطبية اللازمة للقطاع الخاص
ومهارات التواصل
أنت راح تصير عبء، راح يوظفك ستة أو ثمانية شهور
ويلقاك وراتبك عبء
يمكن في بعضهم يقول لك: الرواتب أصلًا ما تسوى
ليش أتعب نفسي، وأقعد أطور؟
يا أخي الخبرة تُشترى، الكلمة هذه
لو قالوا لك: بدون راتب، ادخل
أنت الآن لا ترى من سبقك الآن بخطوتين
والله فلان توظف في وظيفة فلانية مثلًا أو في مكان معين
ويأخذ الراتب الفلاني
يا أخي لا ترى من سبقك الآن بخطوتين
لأنك راح تسبقه بكيلومترات في المستقبل
اللي يجمعه هذا خلال سنة الآن
العشر سنوات، أنت راح تجمعه خلال سنة أو سنتين
أنت انظر لها كذا، وحاول يكون عندك شغف في حب هذا التخصص
وفي تطوير نفسك فيه
لا تفكر أنا كم أخذ؟ أنت ما وصلت مرحلة أنك تأخذ، أنت المفروض تعطي
أعطي، وبعدين أخذ
أنت عمرك شفت، كطالب مثلًا أنك تأخذ الدرجة قبل الاختبار؟
لا، صعبة
لازم تختبر وتعطي المجهود، وتأخذ الدرجة اللي تستحقها
صح
زي كذا هي الحياة
أنت لازم تروح للقطاع الخاص، وتعطيه، وتبذل الجهد فيه
لا تتوقع أنك ترى...
المشكلة دائمًا حتى على مستوى...
ليش أقول لك: في مثلًا 30% عندهم المهارات الطبية اللازمة
بس ما عنده مهارات الإقناع وكذا
لأنه تخرج شهادة علمية كبيرة
ويجيك أحيانًا نرجسية وأحيانًا، ما تعرف
ومنطوي
يا أخي لا تصير كذا، الشهادة هي ورقة أعطتك الأساس
لكن أنت من هنا تنطلق، وتطور نفسك
ليش في 10%؟
مثلًا الرواتب في القطاع الخاص تتراوح ما بين 4-600 ألف
600 ألف بالشهر؟
بالشهر
يمدي أصير طبيب، وللا؟
راحت عليك، خلّك صديقي
مَن هذا، وليش يدخل 600 ألف؟
شخص مطلوب
ليش واحد يبيع لوحته بمئات الملايين؟ شخص مطلوب
لا، بس 600 ألف، أيش يسوي هذا؟
هذا شخص آمنوا فيه الناس، وخدمته ممتازة، وجودته جدًّا عالية
وشخص مُتمكن في التواصل وفي الطب
فهذا شخص نادر، والنادر دائمًا يفرض سعره
بتوصل 600 ألف؟
يصل لـ600 ألف، فلا يغرّك طب الأسنان فيه استثمار
الآن الواحد لازم يفكر أنه يستثمر في نفسه، لا بد يستثمر
راح تخليني أسس عيادة
هذا أصلاً تلقى عنده
مجمعات تلقاه
بعضهم يخاف أنه يفتح مجمعات، لأن يخاف أن تقل جودته
دائمًا رأس المال جبان، فيحاول أن خلاص أنا وصلت، وأكتفي عند طريق
فلا يطمع الواحد في بدايته؟
لا يطمع
يقضي سنين إلى ما يقدر يجيب
لأنه اللي سبقك في الآن في خطوات، راح تسبقه بكيلومترات
فلا تخاف أنت
جميل
فالقناعة دائمًا مثلما قلت لك: هي مفتاحين عشان تصل
لأي نجاح في طب الأسنان، الصدق والأمانة هذه أهم حاجة
جميل، الله العافية دكتور فهد
الله يوفقنا وإياك
أثريتنا صراحة في قطاع يمكن ما قد تكلمنا عنه أبدًا في البرنامج
الله يسعدك، وهذا أحد الأسباب لتواجدي هنا
أنه طورنا لو بكلمة أو ساهمنا في تحسين مستقبل أو تطوير أحد
بالأخير احنا مُستأمنين في المجال الطبي
واحنا عيال هذا البلد، وحريصين على المجال هذا أنه يصل للمستفيد
ولمقدم الرعاية الصحية بشكل أفضل
فهذا الذي نتمناه، وهذا سبب وجودنا
ولعل الله ينفع فيها، إن شاء الله، ويبارك في الجهد
الله يعطيك العافية دكتور فهد
الله يبارك فيك ونراك على خير
شكرًا لكم ولعبد الملك آل سعيد في إنتاج المحتوى
في التحرير: مرام ضبيبان
في إدارة التصوير: ياسر بن غانم
في الإضاءة: عبدالمجيد عمر
في الهندسة الصوتية: عبدالعزيز المزي
في الإخراج الإبداعي: وهّاب موسى
في الإخراج الفني: مجد الملي ومساعده وسيم مُعين
وفي الإنتاج التنفيذي: غيداء التميمي
هذا بودكاست سوالف بزنس، أحد منتجات شركة ثمانية للنشر والتوزيع